[Music]
[Music]
hey
here we are look at these new crazy
names appearing in there [ __ ] sandra
who's never had an
asian
[Laughter]
i was having asian experience in brazil
they got the largest japanese community
outside
outside japan a place called liberty
dodgy yeah i had a girlfriend
her name was uh nordier shubhadi she was
a
part brazilian and part japanese she was
cool man she was real cool
yeah that's just really funny back in
the day
before before we turned the thing on we
were laughing at all the funny names
yeah all the funniest things never had
names
sabrina says love the hair jenny thank
you one of this is one of the new uh
wigs that i got yeah i like i like how
it's color changed on video
yeah because in real life it's purple
yeah but it looks blue on the screen
because wait what it's this color yeah
well that looks blue too
well [ __ ] that doesn't help it's the
lighting in here kind of more that color
i got a green one as well yeah
uh zach says nice week again john thank
you by the way did you see
that post on facebook i tagged you and
which one was that
well how long ago was it because i
haven't been on facebook for the last
several hours and i heard you guys are
talking about somebody who got caught
for killing somebody but we don't know
who it is you're talking about
i saw it yeah i saw that amanda said the
name but it wasn't
immediately familiar i regret to say i
don't keep up with a lot of true crime
stuff because i'm so busy keeping up
with the old true crime stuff that i
don't have a lot of time for the new
true crime stuff
[Laughter]
i love the rings too anything yeah
that's the thing it's like i i wear
these all the time but it's like i
always forget to put them on for the
show because i don't usually have them
on when i'm working i mean today it's
like not only did i
have the presence of mine to do the wig
and i was like oh i even did like
by painting my nails to match and put
jewelry on and everything
read what to say who the hell even is am
i anymore
tom our deal is complete just finished
repo and likes it a lot but i prefer
phantom of the paradise and rocky horror
lol yeah i can see that
yeah you know they're all strong they're
all good i mean i like grease too
yeah i like that one i like uh i like
santa do
[ __ ] but um that song gets stuck in
my head like yeah
that time but uh repo man you know as
far as gothic industrial stuff not repo
man
that's a completely different genetic
opera as far as far as repo genetic
opera
i uh for uh for goth industrial i say
that's the one i liked it
it's got a lot of good songs on it blind
mag songs
she's [ __ ] singing and projecting her
memories through her eyes like a
cat 3d camera projector a lot of good
[ __ ] [ __ ] the grave robbers song
um some of the stuff that what's
it what's his name um roddy uh what's
his name um
um [ __ ] i don't know what you're talking
about
roti roti's songs the guy who [ __ ]
owns shinko
i mean his name was roti um
[ __ ] what was his name a lot of his
stuff paul cervini i think is the name
what's that guy's name
oh no little italian guy
good play you you've seen repo
genetically yeah but it was so long ago
i don't remember i don't remember who
the hell yeah
there's a lot of good songs on it joan
jett shows up
see i totally forgot about it about that
yeah do you realize that uh one of
rhody's
roti's sons was ogre
the guy who had uh ogre was one of the
dudes from skinny puppy
and he was wearing a woman's face
through the whole thing remember you had
some service where you could
get your face changed he had a woman's
face
her skin stretched over his held on with
them
clips clamps it was good
yeah that's right zach said he had sent
me that's right he sent me a flyer for
uh a missing girl that went missing from
from there
and it's like yeah and i've and now i'd
like forgot and
i'm just yeah i i kind of got like
[ __ ] slammed with work today paul
trevino yeah that's right that's awesome
that's mira sorbino's dad yeah yeah
she's taught my sweetie
i like sweeney todd also that's another
good one i like um
did you know they are hold on
i wouldn't say i wouldn't say that um
those are better than repo though
i say they're all about on par with one
another they're all pretty good
yeah i like them all they're all
different they offer something different
sweeney todd that was a good musical it
kind of had that real creepy victorian
gothic
kind of feel to it and there was some
really good really good songs in it
i liked it it was good too yeah
dumb the bomb says did uh jenny did you
finish in search of darkness too yes i
did
uh i've just finished it today and i
enjoyed it as much as the first one i
did as well
i really really liked i mean i loved the
first one but the thing that i liked
about this one maybe slightly better
is that i liked that they focus more on
um a little bit lesser known movies kind
of like second-tier
type of movies because like i said the
first one you know you got to cover all
the
heavy hitters which is cool but this one
they kind of had a lot more leeway to
explore ones that were maybe not as well
known which i thought was really awesome
so maybe i don't know maybe slight edge
to this one
you know yeah um let's see yeah a little
shop of horus is good
yeah i really saw that recently it's
good they actually talked about that on
in search of darkness too as well
i've seen the original like the black
and white one
with uh a very small part by jack
nicholson in there
he's he plays the dentists yeah uh you
know
victim t g if you haven't seen grease
or xanadu you got to see those those are
good too
i even liked greece too yeah it wasn't
bad i mean not as good as
greece one but it is i just i don't know
why i just have like some affection for
it
michelle pfeiffer was in it we grew up
hearing those songs
those songs weren't quite as good as the
first one but no but they were still
good though yeah i mean i
i think i even have the soundtrack album
like on vinyl and everything
i mean that song reproduction was pretty
[ __ ] funny and i really really liked
um
the song that they did at the end like i
can't remember what it's called but like
the
the seasons song i don't remember that
was a good song
if you want to go if you want to really
go back then just go ahead and [ __ ]
watch my fair lady that was pretty good
too
remember that yeah they take the the the
british [ __ ] gutter snipe chick they
call her a gutter snipe
and then got her ready to go to a damn
[ __ ] diplomatic ball
changed her english ever that was a good
one
i liked it i liked it anyway well yeah i
mean you know
some some musicals i can hang with i
actually i actually uh quite like a lot
of
musicals that's a classic though it is
61 maybe
man i don't even remember five well the
movie version yeah
and like prior to that it was stage yeah
yeah
i think so um i was in showboat when i
was a kid
[Laughter]
i remember that one yeah i was in that
one oh it was an annie as well
i wasn't like one of the main characters
i was kind of like a extra
i saw annie live as a little kid at the
shubert theater in california
yeah my mom took me to see it it was
good live
huge auditorium had that little girl
singing and everything yeah it's a hard
knock life and everything i saw it live
well they did it at my high school and
interestingly i went to school with
two girls kim and kathy kershaw i stole
them with their names they were twins
and they looked exactly like annie
they had like the red curly hair the
freckles everything
and they both looked alike obviously
because they were twins so they were in
it
so i thought that was right i was just
in the background like one of the
orphan chicks or something that had to
like scrub the floor
another um the the newer version of
grease
was pretty good too they did a live
television event on one of these cable
channels and when i ordered grease one
it came with
with the new television broadcast and
and greece ii all in the same
bundle and it was like the cost for it
was the same price as just getting
grease
on its own so i would have yeah give me
the deluxe kit yeah why not
and uh the television version was pretty
good too it wasn't really television it
was a cable
yeah it was fox when it wasn't that the
camera yeah remember
yeah they did it live they did rocky
horror too but that one wasn't so good
but the great but the grease one was
really good yeah grayson was good
you could probably pay-per-view that it
had yeah you can
because i watched it again like later
yeah it's rewatchable
and it's live they walk through [ __ ]
sets 3d and they got cameras and people
outside and uh
they're performing it out live outside
at one point weren't they
yeah because yeah on the street yeah and
then then they go inside and go into the
schools and change scenes
i like how they did it they had all
different uh stars
in there um beauty school dropout was
done by uh
bel bev devoe they know that that the
[ __ ] bell biv
yeah yeah number one in the church and
then who else
who else there was a lot of other um for
any of you remember kids in the hall
what's that yeah i was just making a
reference
um oh my god so somebody's screen name
is
man i say it will be fun and their
comment is sorry i'm late had some
closets to pee in
yeah that's cool that's a deep cut see
i was i was asking for some crazy ass
names
and they they show up [ __ ] the asian
experience went really good but sandra
who's never had an asian experience
i saw that right before we started that
cracked up sandra used to be the german
peanut butter advantage
that was a good one
oh [ __ ] marie asked if you two seen
brawl in cell block 99 i have not
sandra are you still spreading peanut
butter all over germany
she's just like wiping it all over all
the buildings all over herself and [ __ ]
[ __ ] she's
live streaming yeah
okay in tom's fantasies
[Laughter]
that's his excuse for everything that's
the only reason why you started taking
those just so you could like do the most
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
[ __ ] thinking about [ __ ] [ __ ]
about people smearing peanut butter on
just everything everything's like it was
i've been moving back in time he's like
now he can't concentrate on anything
anymore because he's so worried
he gets all distracted by oh peanut
butter smearing
boobies well you guys could tell by the
videos that i posted like when i got
drunk last time going out with her last
week
i was mostly just getting [ __ ] sucked
into her cleavage
i kept taking videos of her cleavage i
was it was pulling me in
i was like leeching and unbuttoning
blouses and [ __ ] he really cares he was
talking to somebody else
i was like can you like take some
pictures of my face or something i spent
a long time on this makeup i posted that
[ __ ]
i posted i did i got your face in there
i posted that [ __ ] and i got dudes in
brazil [ __ ] motorcycle friends in
brazil and [ __ ] going
mamma mia like i know man
i know i still didn't get you that night
it was [ __ ] fall asleep
well we were drunk yeah well and i think
that the boobs looked bigger that night
because i think i explained that
the only white bra i have well they're
big it's like super padded
yeah we're gonna need you some more yeah
you just i have some more of those
yeah that all your bras need to be like
that [ __ ] well no because there's
like not i mean there's like this much
padding i didn't realize that because i
ordered them online and i'm like are you
[ __ ] serious yeah i don't need that
and it's like and well the padding is
like on the wrong
in the wrong area [ __ ] great man i
don't know no it's not it's not in the
wrong way
he doesn't he doesn't care oh in the
right area he doesn't care if it's
uncomfortable
yeah yeah no color has nothing to do
with what he did he just he just wants
she's already big
and then she put that on and it's just
like [ __ ]
well when we went when we went to the
halloween party
the first thing yeah that miss tina said
to me
yeah like uh was did you get more
yeah did you get like more boobs yeah
and i was like no it's just
because i hadn't seen her in a couple of
years
oh my god just pepper salt not included
i had to be more specific with my
username apparently
they're talking about their favorite
musicals oh they did a christmas story
live too did they really
terrible in a fun way hmm i just heard i
didn't see the rocky horror one i just
i was gonna watch it and then like
everybody i knew like came
on like [ __ ] facebook and instagram
it was like wow
it's terrible maniac says we gotta
review jesus christ vampire hunter
yeah i saw that i meant to mention that
as well but uh
yeah so what are you talking about
musicals okay so
grease 2 i was all
in the early 80s or mid 80s i guess
i was super into grease too which i
don't know why
um but there was just something about it
i was also super into
sergeant pepper's lonely hearts club
band the one with the bee gees
and alice cooper and george burns in it
yeah for some reason i really dug that
and also i don't know if you guys
remember this
but there was a movie called the pirate
movie and it was
essentially the pirates of penzance but
it had like christy mcnichol was in it
christopher atkins right the dude that
was in
uh the blue lagoon yeah yeah they were
in it
um and looking back on it i'm sure it
was probably awful but it's like for
some reason i was really into it like
back then
i kind of want to see it again but then
i kind of don't because i'd probably be
really embarrassed
yeah tila said i love sgt peppers cheesy
but good
i know it's like it's so weird it's so
weird because
that album is weird and like all of the
songs are weird and it's funny that they
thought that they could make like a
narrative
movie like sort of based on it i don't
know
it was just such a strange idea sergeant
pepper yeah
the robert stigwood movie that had the
bg's in it playing
sergeant pepper's little i remember when
it was new and it would play it on early
cable
it was a cable yes it was on there all
the time it was a very early cable
service we had in california as a
prototype it was called on tv
you know i i bet you i bet you taylor
remembers on
just on on tv yep and he had to get a
box and everything that was a weird deal
you know back in the 70s you're like you
have to get a box and
and if somebody comes to your house and
puts a box in your house that was a
just a weird concept you know putting
the box in your box yeah later it
changed
hbo but it used to be called on tv and
um
sergeant pepper's came out
when it came out mtv was not a big deal
i don't even think it existed
well mtv started in late summer of 81.
at least okay so and i think i think
sergeant pepper's might have been a year
or two before you guys can think it was
78
right i want to say that came out in 78
like in the theater so there was no
music videos that you know not really
sergeant pepper's was kind of like
kind of like a video tribute album
yeah all right which that's and that's
how it played
it was like a tribute album to
the beatles but it was performed by
several bands by other people other
bands you know you had it was mostly
headlining was the bee gees yeah they
played the main band they were really
good guys they played the good guys
then you had aerosmith and alice cooper
and a couple others i don't remember
they were playing the bad guys
yeah and there was was an earthquake and
fire was in there too i think yeah yeah
it was awesome in its day it's still fun
to watch
t says she liked it i love i love it
when you watch it it's just [ __ ]
wacky
it is it's crazy it's the 70s style
stuff you [ __ ] light up a [ __ ]
joint or you drop a hit acid or you
[ __ ] start getting drunk and you just
watch it and enjoy it you don't try to
overthink it
xanadu is kind of like that you don't
want to overthink it too much just enjoy
it yeah it's just like you know kind of
it's a show it's roller skates it's a
video album
okay girls coming out of walls yeah you
know
that was one of the things i remembered
about as a kid that impressed me
of of sergeant pepper's this was in a
time when i was
you know maybe i don't know [ __ ] 10
11 12 13 probably around that time i
think when i first saw it
and um i was kind of heavily influenced
by
heavy metal magazine which was like a
[ __ ] sci-fi comic book that
was around in eerie and creepy magazines
um and just california at that time
would have [ __ ] quite a
sexual undertone and everything and so
did all of the [ __ ]
movies that we were watching and stuff
that was and that particular movie stood
out
especially one scene with mr mustard
and he had these two robots that were
these shiny black
bondage [ __ ] girls i thought they
were gold
they were black although i haven't seen
in a long time remember black pvc and
shiny black plastic
and like lit up lit up [ __ ] eyes oh
yeah
they were sex bots yeah and there was
something about that scene man that
[ __ ] just kind of
as a kid i was like i want to god damn
robots
you know that's how it was
i'm gonna [ __ ] those robots i was
probably like
10 11 12.
[ __ ] yeah i think that was kind of like
the very [ __ ] beginning of like
fetish
bondage type [ __ ] tastes and things
yeah
i seem to remember the robots their hair
kind of looks like tires
yeah it was like wires and coils or
something yeah
and it kind of looked like a brillo pad
a little yeah well
that all kind of tied in with stuff that
you would see
in the comic books that i was reading
yeah like eerie cut you know uncle eerie
and cousin creepy magazines
they were they were weird sci-fi horror
and there was always like sexual
undertones to them yeah you know
but like the uh the movie that i
recommended uh t
saw it it was called heavy metal and the
comic book was like that
and it had rock and [ __ ] and rock
background it was i think it was
still a good movie that holds up to
today animated movie
and it's heavily heavy sexual undertones
and drug references
lots of it which was very which was
pretty controversial back then so i kind
of feel like
it was yeah but then it's before council
culture and any kind of thing of [ __ ]
morality uh
uh hollywood was subversive and they
were gonna do what they wanted to do
they liked subversive entertainment
and uh they really subversive you know
they didn't care if it was
you know pc or not they just did it you
know
that's why you had [ __ ] like blue lagoon
and [ __ ]
what was the one baby what was that one
[ __ ]
pretty baby pretty baby which [ __ ]
bordering on [ __ ]
underage girls you know [ __ ] it's
weird [ __ ] you know
yeah you did it anyway there was kind of
well i feel like there was kind of a
mini boom and sort of
underage girl yeah going on because they
did lolita themed
[ __ ] movies yeah because you know
like kubrick did
the lolita adaptation yeah they made
another one in the 90s with jeremy irons
which i remember thinking was pretty was
pretty good
it's not as good as the kubrick one but
you know i can't remember who played
lolita in that one though 78 was a
release date for
sergeant oh i got it right yeah um
and what was i saying oh talking about
like musicals yeah i said the pirate
movie if anybody
if anybody knows what i'm talking about
like i said christy mcnichol was in it
i'm sure it was terrible because like i
don't remember
but um uh you guys have you guys seen
hedvig in the angry inch because that's
like a really awesome
newer musical i can't remember when that
came out nineties two thousands
it's really good we have a channel in
here i don't know who this used to be
but now it's called the crustling
the crosstalk the crosslink that's the
masterpiece
[Laughter]
he says now nobody's having sex in
california yeah you should have seen
well you were around probably but back
in the 70s in the early 80s it was
[ __ ] wild now that [ __ ]
vibe is actually in in in florida i got
pictures to prove
[Laughter]
he's got pictures of proof just pep just
peppers
that's another crazy one on there i
don't know who you guys used to be you
might want to tell me
who the crosstalk of just pepper is uh
anyway um
heavy metal is legit awesome it was a
good movie it says it was so awesome the
south park parroted it yeah
yeah heavy metal was on the showtime the
other night cartoon work reminded me of
that eon flux on mtv
man you guys remember liquid television
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and eon flux the original one yeah yeah
that was kind of like all
i used to [ __ ] one of my favorite
things on there
on liquid television which you didn't
know it was like mtv used to show it
like late at night it was oh you got
that thing yeah
god i'm trying to talk i'm sorry man i
smell that smoke um i haven't had one
since the last show i was trying to uh
now i forgot what i was saying um
somebody on flux and
oh like okay so liquid television um
mtv used to show it on sunday nights
i think before 120 minutes and it was
like
clips of kind of underground animation
so it was kind of like you know there'd
be like five minutes of this and two
minutes of this and other things
and it wasn't entirely animation because
one of my favorite things on there
was um art school girls of june
which i thought was really funny which
was sort of live action but it had like
some animation kind of [ __ ] in it too
but there was some like some good [ __ ]
on there yeah what's funny is that
i was going to make an mtv tribute shirt
with the original mtv logo the white one
on a black shirt
like um oh boy from uh uh oh boy from
predator one was wearing in predator one
uh [ __ ]
what was what was the name of the
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] man
the coffee show is just time going on
what's that who's that
what's that doing huh
you know what i'm talking about um jesse
the body
i was going to make that shirt but then
i started thinking about it i said man
people won't realize won't get the
reference
no of course they won't get the
reference they're going to think of
today's version of
mtv and today's mtv is [ __ ] lame
so i'm going to well it's not music
videos it's not well that's what i mean
it'd be one thing if mtv was gone if
you'd like gone
out of business like was still playing
music videos but that didn't happen
that first 15 20 years of mtv was 15
years
i guess won it the first 15 years was
really good i can't remember okay so
we're gonna go down in the late 90s
well yeah in the 90s they started doing
they did the real world which was kind
of like the first tv reality show
which was actually pretty good i used to
i watched that
that was the end of empty but then after
that like they were like hey these are
much cheaper
to make and they made more money and um
kind of reality tv was kind of
coming into like everybody's watching
that [ __ ] so they're like okay well
as far as i know uh you know mtv is
probably all reality shows though
i think it's all preachy [ __ ] now i
think it's all reality shows
i mean for a long time they had
something like you know 16 and pregnant
uh that kind of stuff that was the last
time i saw it that's all that was on
there it was like
when it was like jerry springer type
[ __ ] yeah you know what i mean
like yeah but it's funny because like
our generation growing up it wasn't
though it was like a
video radio station and it had all these
[ __ ] cool british new wave bands on
it when it first opened that was like
that for
many years and then they started they
started rotating through though you know
it had
as people started to make music videos
they started to have like
at certain times you'd have rock
metal you know and then you'd have um
new wave and
top 40 and um i think you'd have like
maybe like r
b or something you know and then you'd
have whole
schedules with specials and it got more
and more complicated as it went on
but i think for me and jenny growing up
during the formative years
of mtv for us was when it was still new
when it was like
in its first year or maybe like year
four or five
when it was still kind of primitive it
was it was
better it's a lot better because you
could you never really
could tell what you were going to see
just out of the blue
a new video would appear like who are
these guys and it was usually something
that was pretty good it was like
kind of homemade you know now you got
youtube for that
which watching some of these new kind of
underground youtube music music videos
that local bands make and
i'll be like you know i kind of miss mtv
in that first few years of it but i said
but you know these are actually
on par or better than the music videos
we had in very early mtv
yeah i mean until mtv really took a
foothold
in the culture um you know you
i don't like record companies didn't
want to pay for you to make a video
because they're like what the [ __ ] are
you going to do with that but like once
mtv got big then they would yeah then
they became a million-dollar affair
jackson came out
well and particularly after like you
know duran duran and people like that
that spent like [ __ ] tons of money on
their videos and they got like
hugely famous yeah so yeah i mean before
that it was just like real diy kind of
[ __ ] yeah
and you know back then you couldn't do
diy [ __ ] that looked all that good
no i feel like well back in the day like
mtv used to they used to have
shows in the in that they would have
like a block of it it's like they had
head bangers ball which was all heavy
metal
that are 120 minutes which is all
alternative it was later they had
[ __ ] like that but yeah that was a
little bit later and then
um i remember like in the late 80s early
to mid 90s
yeah they did um before 120 minutes they
started showing
the young ones you know so they'd show
like a comedy
they show like the young ones in the
comic strip like from uk
and then they would show liquid
television so they kind of tried to do
like some weird but they kind of kept it
weird you know what i mean they didn't
really have any reality shows until they
did the real world
for me when i think of the old mtv i'm
thinking of like flock of seagulls with
like the photograph [ __ ]
video and uh you know maybe
our lives in jeopardy yeah yeah
just [ __ ] weird [ __ ] with all the
monsters i used to love that video when
i was a kid because it had monsters in
it
yeah even when i was a kid i was just
like monsters yay
i was into that [ __ ] all the videos that
were scary
and i remember the video for um
white wedding and i still love that part
where he put the ring on the on her
finger and like her
all the blood came out all those [ __ ]
hollow notes videos she's a man eater
it was all like [ __ ] well like 80s noir
yeah i remember that [ __ ]
oh my god it's so good
[Laughter]
i didn't like them at the time but i
think i i like it in retrospect
i think in retrospect yeah i think i
like them a little bit better no they
they overplayed it so much that you
[ __ ] were like man
[ __ ] stop playing that [ __ ]
where's the good [ __ ] yeah i kept
waiting for like the cycle like furs or
something to come on yeah
i was listening at that time i was
listening to a radio station out in l.a
called kroq k rock
and it that ended up being like a huge
radio station
later on but even i heard of that yeah
in the early 80s though it was like
that's where you heard the first
new wave yeah like you would hear
[ __ ] billy idol's first
early stuff you know would come out uh
duran duran [ __ ] off the first album
like planet earth
you know a night boat and they're
playing that um
i love the nightboat yeah it's so creepy
adam ant they'd play
[ __ ] [ __ ] um
desperate but not serious yeah yeah
they're and that was and that's pretty
cutting edge for [ __ ]
mainstream radio broadcast you know like
they wouldn't play that in mississippi
at that time they're like what the [ __ ]
is that
well yeah i mean you have to think only
l.a i mean yeah
i mean i grew up in yeah i mean new york
and stuff like that had that but i grew
up in daytona beach florida all
the only radio stations that we had were
like country stations
or like old rockstars they you know they
played
the doors they played like the allman
brothers [ __ ] like that nobody played
new wave
in on the radio yeah well in the early
80s
internet internet democratized
everything so did cable tv
really to be honest cable tv changed
everything
yeah with cable tv you you had
mtv or at least you got something like
night tracks
or you know they had a couple of other
little rip-offs in the south
where people kids in the deep south
instantly started listening to [ __ ] like
prince
yeah prince and duran duran well yeah
they came over like yep
yep that's that's for us they're playing
with violence the violet femmes
and there was your your redneck your
your redneck
[ __ ] um what do you call it
your redneck reproduction system okay
starting to break down
because the [ __ ] that was
the [ __ ] that was local and normal in
the deep south was no longer
cool you were now exposed to like a
broader range of things
so you're like man this [ __ ] ain't cool
with it you know bluegrass music and
crap like that and [ __ ] you know
dukes of hazzard
[Laughter]
but all my relatives love you you know
what i mean
um oh i'm just laughing because tila is
talking about weird al's spoof song i
love it in jeopardy
you know what i had that album i
actually had a couple of uh weird al's
albums i had uh dare to be stupid
and what was whatever was the one before
that you know what
a lot of people like his parody songs
are funny but
a lot of people don't realize that he
did some original songs too and they are
hilarious probably my favorite one is
called nature trail the hell
and it's like a it's like a horror movie
trailer alright t you being a california
girl i feel like i'm broadcasting the t
but she's a california girl there was
the first time i heard i heard uh weird
al
was on a california radius radio program
i don't know if it played nationwide i
think it was just
just southern california maybe just
california it was a show called dr
dementos
oh everybody's heard of doctor okay yes
was that just a california thing
i don't think so because i well i mean
unless it was
uh it might have been picked up by other
yeah you know
stations later i think it was a
california thing i mean i've heard i
heard of him like
way back then and he's he introduced the
world i think to to weird alien
yeah and then he would just play all
kinds of
he was a dj who would play all kinds of
weird [ __ ] songs
i got some barns and barns on there yeah
yeah yeah fish
heads yeah yeah exactly exactly bars and
barns and all that crap
and uh [ __ ] and and funny frank zappa
songs
yeah and stuff and you know and
for halloween he'd have a theme you know
it was
it was just a little radio show yeah
esther says dr demento was on in
philadelphia yeah so i think it was like
nationwide
because i yeah i didn't know where he
was
broadcasting from i guess he was kind of
like art bell where he broadcast from
his local area and then the other
stations would people pick it up yeah
but i don't know i i don't know where he
was broadcasting from for all i know it
might have been philadelphia
but he was sucking huge in southern
california everybody listened to him
especially if you were a kid
you listen dr demento yeah because he
played like crazy yeah
yeah and then and there he would also
like play i think
[ __ ] like little radio skits or
something little recorded
i think so although it's been a long
time a long time dj maniac said
nightflight predated mtv by about six
months and it was essentially youtube
before youtube was in a concept
i remember seeing night flight on i want
to say it was the usa network but i
could be
remembering that wrong i think it was
either usa or tbs
oh yeah maybe it was tbs right i
remember missing i remember being at my
grandpa's house
watched that a lot too yeah yeah yeah
yeah i remember that
yeah they showed videos grampur's hammer
says mary lynn rice cub was in the
weezer video the good life did you know
that
uh no i didn't know that holy crap i
don't even remember
i don't remember like i like weezer but
i haven't seen a lot of their videos
mary lynn was also friend with fiona
apple
not really she's friends with fiona
apple and then another one what's the
name
something or other crow cheryl shell
crow i mean she's friends with shell
crow fiona apple
for a long time i thought those two
chicks were the same chick yeah they're
not
they're not silly me
yeah fourth drawdown says in the uk i
post videos of jenny
i post videos of jenny at the club and
marilyn [ __ ] thumbs about
a video i want to [ __ ] famous
jenny's boobs and she's a lot of people
one or the right one she's like both of
them
yeah she's like i'll thumb up anything
she's down the boat she knows
knows she knows how i am yeah well
fourth drawer down says in the uk my
first experience of mtv was music box
that aired during the night the first
video i ever saw on it
was listen like thieves by nxs you
remember that song
i you know what's weird i'm not a huge
nxs fan
i like a grand total of two count them
two in xs songs which are
don't change i love that song and
uh i can't remember where the other one
is but i know there's one more
maybe somebody will remind me i think
what it is is that
when i was in high school and
you know i'm super into [ __ ] the
smiths and the cure and depeche mode and
alien sex fiend and bauhaus and [ __ ]
like that
i had a friend who was really
really into nxs i mean
really and i didn't have a car and she
did
so i used to drive around with her all
the time
and she played that [ __ ] nxs tape not
kick the one that came out before that
and she just played it on [ __ ]
constant loop and i got so sick of it
that i thought i was going to
kill myself so i think that's probably
why so now every time i'm at ibar and
they play nxs i'm like
then i have to go out to the front bar
so i can chill out thank you david lots
of compliments on the shirt crustal
levels of b.a
[Laughter]
yeah speaking of shirts um got new ones
coming but i'm out of emulsion
so i had to i ordered new i ordered a
quart of emulsion that should be here in
a couple of days
yeah and then once that's done i'm gonna
start one of the i'm making another
crustal shirt it's that same
uh pliskin logo but it's about three
times that size it'll cover a whole
shirt
that way if i ever get like an extra
extra extra [ __ ] large
i can put a big image in it that'll
[ __ ] even it out
but you that big image will would be
good even on a small or a medium t-shirt
though it would look really cool
i was looking at it i was going man you
know on an od green t-shirt
with that pliskin image done in black
black
ink that would look really good yeah
probably would we should probably expect
i thought we bought some black ink like
a while back and then um got a couple
more got another 13 o'clock shirt that
looks like a ouija board it looks really
cool
uh a new logo it's kind of like this but
it's got lines
uh the other one is uh um what's it
what's the other one
it's um do you remember no she doesn't
remember either
that's a couple more sorry i was i was
reading something just pepper said you
should make one that says
every day i'm crusalin
[Laughter]
yeah i would totally read that
i would totally uh wear that welcome to
the crustal sphere yeah welcome to the
brussels spear
uh seth says my friend used to do drugs
with michael hutchins in melbourne
he told me he didn't come across so sexy
back then he wore his zebra print suit
for days and smelled
good voice though i still can't remember
i don't like okay so dermot said need
you tonight
yeah that's an okay song but that wasn't
the one i was thinking of don't change
is one that i really like that song
and then there's one oh i remember what
it is it's uh the one thing
the video where that that big long table
and they're all eating like
pomegranates or whatever look at tina
said with the cats crawling a little bit
look at the pair of boxer shorts it says
growth
on it yeah
tom doesn't remember because he's
usually like drunker they just it just
comes out of his
comes out of the subconscious out of his
rectal cavity
he's always got to talk about [ __ ] like
that i'll tell you these women secretly
want to peg a [ __ ] they just do
it's i don't make it it's not a secret
over there laughing like a damn wicked
witch
i know that's my favorite thing that's
my favorite thing
it comes from the collective art causes
just the collective unconscious yes
thomas are the bomb says tila yeah
i do love that every day i'm crystal and
kind of uh
that's pretty funny i don't know if i
want to disturb the crustal sphere
though
you see what do you think might happen i
don't know
i'm so i'm um i'm superstitious
superstitious about crustal sometimes it
grips me maybe i should not
transgress across against the cross
yeah you know what i mean it's like that
shall not take the crustal in vain that
type of deal you know what i mean
[ __ ]
you might you might break the crustal
magic
[Laughter]
crustal crustal has it can be confirmed
to me
you know on several times hold on you
know what what i got to put a [ __ ]
hat on i reached level one oh oh
level one level level one green green
green green combat hat level one all
right
because because crustle
was the first man to report to observe
and report the [ __ ] phoenix phoenix
lights
sure then i i i i believe in the phoenix
lights
extra testicles and and and ex
extraterrestrials with extra testing
maybe
testicles not judging and and i know
that
crustal is the chosen one
[Laughter]
crossover's the chosen one
fourth throw down says defcon3 well okay
so how many hats do you have so you have
hat lists you got like four heads
and then you have four hats yeah so
there's a certain order to them that's
what i mean so is it defcon
wait so is it defcon four or defcon
three because it goes down right defcon
one is [ __ ]
is that [ __ ] nuclear conflict is
imminent
you know what i mean that why is this
man my [ __ ] keeps going
yeah that's what i thought it goes down
right yeah i thought i saw war games in
the 80s
four i think is the normal state i
thought it was five
maybe five none of that [ __ ] matters
though i don't think i don't think the
that that's only like norad and i'm not
sure norad still exists it's gonna be a
new
agency that new part of the air force
that does that
probably that space force because
all that nuclear stuff now is all space
born
none of it has to do with ground-based
radar
radar yeah david jones radar have you
guys got tusk yet we have not
i've been meaning to say we don't we
yeah we've seen it but we haven't we
don't have a copy though it's a good
movie
yeah i kind of it's it's so weird it's
just disturbing as hell
that's the kind of [ __ ] that does kind
of freak me out most horror movies don't
but
those those weird that weird twisted
[ __ ] like twist like tusk
yeah that was like [ __ ] that's some
crazy especially like the end of that
like if you really think about the
implications of how that ended i'm like
wow that's [ __ ] up
he was turned into a walrus like it's
funny but
really not all that funny it's not that
funny if you think about it
oh [ __ ] um david said consider it set
thank you so much awesome okay yeah it
was good
it was good yeah we saw it on we watched
a lot of slides or something
i'm at level one now so i can talk about
it we got a uh
review coming up on um elvis and nixon
or is it nixon and elvis i think it's
elvis dixon well elvis has to go first
yeah
king comes before the president yeah we
watched that
yeah we watched it last night we
actually saw it in the theater when it
came out
yeah i liked it i liked it
it's one of those kind of strange but
true movies
um elvis did weasel his way into the
oval office to see president nixon
for a secret meeting and well it's not a
secret because everybody knows everybody
knows about it now
elvis believed it was a secret mission
and it had
it and this isn't some [ __ ] that
they pulled out of their ass you know
what i mean
this really did happen there's pictures
to prove it
and uh there's records that recorded it
and
elvis friends contributed to this movie
so it's not something they
made up yeah jerry shilling was like the
producer
yeah it's evidently it well first of all
if it matches up with everything that i
had read and
and legends that i had heard as
being young growing up at least part of
the time in mississippi
okay elvis is legendary in mississippi
and it wasn't something my generation
was really into it was something that
like
your parrots were into but they kind of
passed it down to us
these weird stories about him i mean
[ __ ] that
he was on par with jesus really yeah
yeah
that elvis can make it rain yeah
and i only heard these other guys my age
you know
[ __ ] 10 11 12 saying this [ __ ]
but i was you know grew up part of time
in california and i'm coming to
mississippi and it's two totally
different worlds
and they're telling me that elvis could
make it rain from the back of a
convertible
and i'm going what the [ __ ] and they
were saying yeah it was like jesus and
i'm like
it's like jesus and i'm looking on the
front of my [ __ ] boy david keys
mantle he's the one that wrote that book
about
free state of jones looking at his
second mantle
and his dad's got a got a [ __ ]
painting of jesus over the mantle
all right over the fireplace but on the
mantle
there's elvis stuff so it kind of made
this
i was able to perceive that there was a
in the minds
of southerners at least of that
generation that there wasn't much
difference between
elvis and jesus it was about to say yeah
because you know
elvis was singing gospel music at that
time so there was a religious
connotation
to elvis and a lot of the mythos that
you heard these stories about
elvis sounded false to me as a kid
it sounded like something they made up
but as i got older
he ended up getting being confirmed you
know that yeah he did
he did visit the president he can't make
it rain though
that we know of well okay later on
it was confirmed that his friends said
he was in
in the in the cadillac and the
convertible
yeah in driving a convertible
and he said something about the the rain
and immediate rain
and it rained and then elvis said see i
could make it rain
it was no i don't i wasn't there but
that was a myth
or a legend well i kind of feel like
that's kind of uh
you know confirmation bias a little bit
going on there because how many times
you go around going man i wish it would
rain it doesn't rain but you forget all
those times
you only remember the one time that you
said you wished it would and then right
this is folk ideology let me have that
that that uh
lighter again here this is all folk
legend and [ __ ]
which me being into religious mythicism
and everything now i can look back and
[ __ ] see that a lot of what
what i was being told a lot of what i
experienced it was was was mythicism
okay and religions are mythic
all of them and probably not based in
anything that actually happened is based
on things that people were saying
and there's always a reason why they're
saying it and then they write it down
and they write it down in a way to
really empower priests really
that's what it what basically what
religions are it's a way of getting
power
and control not necessarily for a bad
reason just
like a form of government
anyway as it went on you know [ __ ]
elvis died and there were a lot of
people in the south that just couldn't
accept that
yeah clearly so elvis sightings
you know people [ __ ] swearing up and
down that he did not die
then you got orion shows up who sounds
exactly like elvis
and um and kind of looks like himself
kind of
he's from around that same area and uh
so it's the same kind of culture and he
was a little bit younger than elvis
i think yeah maybe his soul just
translated yeah well they were trying to
people would try to rationalize it
they're trying to rationalize that well
maybe he would see somehow
channeling the spirit of elvis sure
because yeah i mean you know you can
convince yourself to believe anything if
you want to bad enough
well it all makes sense if you
understand
deep south culture of mississippi
alabama tennessee
northern parts of louisiana louisiana
okay even probably panhandle florida
oh yeah big time okay it's all the same
it's about the same culture genetically
you're talking about the same people
pretty much when you talk about the
white people at least
their their religion
the southern baptist is a self-styled
religion
it's basically if you actually analyze
it
it's a it's a
it's an exorcism cult it it it's
it's a it's a type of christianity that
is about spirits
exorcisms and channeling things like the
spirit of the lord and
casting out demons that's exorcism okay
so it kind of makes sense that people
with a southern baptist
background might think that somebody
could channel the spirit of somebody
sure so that's what they're talking
about even though they probably
consciously aren't
saying this in the recent recesses of
their minds because of the kind of
religious traditions they have
they're open to the possibility that
something like this could happen
it's really fanboyism though yeah that's
what it really was
yeah but they're trying to rationalize
it to something it's because as soon as
he took that mask off
orion and he goes no that is not elvis
then the spell was broken he didn't
sound like him he sounded just like him
they wanted to they wanted to hold out
the belief they wanted the fantasy
that that elvis had come back yeah
people i feel like people in general
maybe not so much nowadays but i feel
like people in general are a lot more
comfortable with
fantasy than they are with reality yeah
you know well this we saw the movie uh
elvis and nixon and um
it's a good explanation of who this dude
is i was always kind of fascinated with
him just kind of
you know on the level of who he was as a
man you know
not so much his music i mean i really
wasn't too much into his music it was
gospel
and it sounds good but not really my
thing you know
it was just kind of like the mythology
around him i thought was very
interesting
you know and this uh you can learn a lot
from him through this movie
and the movie is only a small part of
his life but it gives up a lot
of his ideology what he was thinking
he wants to go meet the president
to get the powers of a special agent at
large
to fight a drug epidemic
to save the union from communist
what do you call it communist of
subversion yeah and to save it basically
from like
collapse and race war and he and
because he he told nixon he liked those
damn hippies he didn't like the hippies
and he put a lot of it on the beatles
you gotta [ __ ] see
he kind of blames the beatles kind of
blames the beatles that the beatles did
it
[Laughter]
he wants this badge he shows up to the
white house with him and his buddies
armed to the teeth [ __ ] pimped out
[ __ ] 1911
45s he goes to see the president [ __ ]
armed
yes couldn't
or shouldn't they well you see he
explained it to them
[ __ ] secret services like we asked
you if you had any [ __ ] illegal
weapons well
yeah these aren't illegal i legally
possess these i'm a sheriff's deputy
because they were all deputized by the
sheriff
over in tennessee where they lived they
all had law enforcement credentials
which sounds kind of crazy but you gotta
remember that [ __ ]
elvis was [ __ ] a staff sergeant in
the army in the [ __ ] armored unit
and was [ __ ] competent with weapons
he was a trained soldier
um he was also the most famous person
the most famous person in the world
pretty much in the world yeah
and all of his boys were basically
were all trained so they were
sheriffs and [ __ ] cops and soldiers
it's just when you look at them you
really wouldn't think that they were
because they were just
pimped out in these [ __ ] southern
gothic [ __ ] mafia looking [ __ ]
70s outfits you know just with
[ __ ] white leather holsters and
gold-plated 45s and [ __ ] silver
bullets and [ __ ] yeah
everything they were just everything
yeah he the the uh
the pistol that he gave to nixon yeah it
was like it had
silver bullets with it in case he needs
to kill anywhere
yeah yeah i guess yeah and you see they
were both military men
so he gave nixon a commemorative model
19
uh 1911 45 auto that had been
inscribed with um
president nixon's name the names of his
units and the time in which he served in
the theater in which he served
i think was in korea when i think it was
korea
i can't remember and so he knew what
campaigns nixon was into so they you
know just
two military guys rubbing each other's
rhubarb you know what i mean [ __ ]
pretty much yeah but that's exactly the
kind of thing a military dude would give
another military man
you know something to commemorate his
military service
so you elvis knew exactly and all kinds
of weird [ __ ] happens in this movie you
got to [ __ ] see it
the whole movie is just about them
setting up this meeting and then the
meeting happening but
it's like it's really really funny it's
funny it's like in a dry kind of way
it's really funny
because it's it's it's real this really
did yeah that's pretty much what they
did they didn't like over sailing or
anything
and this really did happen and it and
you would it sounds
so bizarre and it's so crazy you would
think that this didn't happen
no it did happen
he just walked up to the front gates of
the white house and [ __ ] told them to
give the president this letter i'll wait
for him he wants i'm gonna go in there
and talk to him
that's what it was like thank you mango
like you can you can just walk in and
[ __ ] talk to the president elvis
kennedy and he did
well now they did dick him around a
little bit because he did kind of go up
so i want to say too that uh the movie
because um someone asked or victor
asked um is called elvis and nixon
it came out a few years ago i remember
we saw in the theater
and then you were talking about the
other day so you ordered a copy uh
michael shannon plays elvis
yeah he's great uh kevin spacey plays
nixon um johnny knoxville is in it
and i can't remember the name of the guy
that plays um jerry shilling but jerry
shelling was the guy that was like the
producer on it so
it's from his recollections or from his
uh story or whatever
and that we're a creepy [ __ ]
that little boy yeah he said kevin
speaking
kevin's crazy yeah yeah i don't like
kevin spacey all right i think that
dude's a [ __ ] creep he's a creep but
he's a good actor
yeah but he is he knocks nixon out of
the [ __ ] park
he he does this role i would never trust
a son of mine or i would never trust him
around any children of mine that
[ __ ]
has been all kinds of allegations are
behind
[ __ ] yeah i guess i don't get joe
esther thank you esther yeah which read
author super chats jenny
uh mango said elvis will always live
yeah esther says tom's enthusiasm that's
for your enthusiasm
well i'm giving you guys a heads up so
you guys can stream it it's only a
couple bucks
uh elvis and nixon and and we're gonna
do the review for it and it it it's
gonna
yeah we'll probably do it sunday i think
because yeah we just watched it last
night and i liked it just as much as we
did we saw in the theater it was better
the second time
i was able to pick up a lot more well
yeah you catch a lot more like i said
and it's not even a big it's
it's basically just based around this
one i mean pretty much the first three
quarters of the movie is that i'm trying
to set
up the meeting the meeting and then like
the meeting happening
there's a lot of mysterious stuff in it
too
me as a as a as a novice
elvis historian
did elvis really believe this [ __ ]
that he was going to become a secret
agent and go undercover
and defeat he did you know what's or did
he just want that [ __ ] badge
because he had a bunch of other badges
and the whole
movie starts with him getting pissed off
over what he saw on television in his
command center in the elvis command
center which he had at graceland there's
a bunch of tvs on a ball well you got
all the money
yeah as well he was watching he shot the
television because he got sick of seeing
that [ __ ]
and then he called his buddies and he
was looking kind of depressed and he's
like i'm gonna get another badge
i kind of feel like we're getting into
the badge um
let me comment because cess just said
jenny in the paper the other day had an
article about summerton man his body's
being exhumed
i heard about that i didn't see it in
the paper i actually saw it on brain
scratch
like he was talking about that how they
are gonna like exhume his body and
hopefully they can find out who that
dude is maybe
and they've done a new um uh a new uh
what do you call it like an art artistic
rendering of him as well
which is a lot better than the first one
but um
yeah we were talking about last night
and i was kind of like you know what
the thing about elvis and i guess
anybody that's as famous as that as rich
and famous as that and
was as rich and famous for as long as he
was
um elvis lived in a bubble yeah you know
what i'm saying
and that really comes across in this
movie because
he really did he did a lot of stuff just
because it didn't occur to him that he
couldn't you know what i'm saying
because he just the way he lived
everything was kind of open to him
everything was done for him
everything was so you know he goes to he
just like
strolls into like an airport and wants
to get on a plane
with a gun with guns it's like he
doesn't have a driver's license
like you know they ask him for id he
shows them a badge
it's like he doesn't have any
identification and it's like it doesn't
occur to him that he would need anything
like that like a normal mortal would
so all of this stuff about i'm sure he
just thought that he could waltz up to
the white house and just like waltz into
you know the the oval office and talk to
the president yeah
and then it would be fine yeah well part
of that is
southern culture and his status in
southern culture at that time
all right i i can maybe explain to that
later but
another thing is is that you point out
is that not only did he
think that he could just walk in to the
oval office
he pretty much thought he could walk
into the oval office and treat the
president
as an equal yeah which is one of the
funniest which is what he did well and
he did
yeah he got away with it got away with
it yeah because like they have this
very very funny scene like where the
like one guy who's played by
uh colin hanks tom hanks his son and
he's uh
kind of one of the advisors or whatever
and he's telling like all these rules
it's like you know you have to come in
the door and
you can't sit down until he says and
don't eat his m ms and
don't drink adopt dr pepper and all this
other kind of [ __ ] and then elvis comes
in and just does everything he's not
supposed to do
sure but not but every one of those
rules but he's not doing it out of
malice though it's just
he's just doing it because he's doing it
he was doing it to show the president
that he was an equal
yeah that he's he sees himself as the
thing he doesn't have to do those rules
he's going to break those rules on
purpose to show him that he's strong
enough to do that so therefore
you should recognize me i recognize you
that's exactly
yeah and then i mean gets back to what i
was talking about about
the the old-fashioned culture of the
deep south
my dad was like this i know i know all
about it my granddad
was even worse i never met him he died
before it
it is an honor-based society not a
legalistic society they don't care about
laws or rules
everything is about honor and truth you
know i mean handshake
eye contact you're a man i'm a man
we're gonna you know what i mean that's
those are society's rules but they're
not
our rules we're talking man to man it's
that is what
he's talking about and
dudes like that don't usually don't go
far very far away from home
they're in an environment where that
flies everybody's like that there
well yeah they're a big fish in a small
yeah exactly
in elvis case he when he left the south
he was so
famous he could retain that mentality
without having to conform to the
broader social norms so he never evolved
outside of basically a tribal mentality
i know exactly what where he's coming
from the idea of course he could get
onto a plane with a gun
he's elvis he's honorable everybody
knows him
everybody knows he's a good yeah and the
thing about him an authority figure
and he was you know and he probably he
was a good guy he didn't do anything he
didn't do anything terrible
to anybody really so um and the fact
that
he was so famous like allowed him to get
away with it
which you know just reinforced the idea
yeah that he could just do whatever he
wanted because
he was alvin but if he wasn't famous he
would have tried that same [ __ ] and got
in trouble for it i mean
any if it if it was anyone other than
aldo yeah yeah yeah
you get away with that right right right
it was only because he was elvis that's
why he got away with it yeah
that's what he's doing and um he i think
he thought reality was like that for
everybody
i think he genuinely did think that well
because like i said he
he didn't really i mean he lived
somewhat of a normal life
maybe more than because a couple people
in the comments brought up michael
jackson
michael jackson i think is like an even
worse case because michael jackson was
famous
from when he was little um so i don't
really think he had
much of a normal life at all yeah i
think elvis did he was in the military
and [ __ ] like that i mean he was famous
by then too but
i think he had a little bit more of a
normal life than michael jackson did
but as i said anybody with that much
money anybody with that much fame you're
recognized by everybody wherever you go
you just can't live like a normal person
it's impossible he was
southern he was a southern man of his
time
and his class he came from poor
sharecroppers
he was a southern republican he was
white dixiecrats couldn't stand him
because he
quote had negro ways end quote
where he came from white democrats or
dixiecrats
they were clan adjacent or clan members
you can there's a movie called free
state of jones
and my family's from jones county will
explain all that
so he is sees himself as a as a
republican
in the for in in in the aspect of
the union a unionist not a confederate
but a unionist
that everybody is supposed to be
together it's a civic
nationalism that's that not
ethnonationalism
the the dixiecrats were
ethno-nationalists they're very
different interpretation of
nationalism the cloak he was self-made
he was intelligent very very charming he
was a king
in many many ways just on the on the on
the backs of
him having a good heart and a and
charisma uh but he was still
very kind of simple uh they mentioned in
the movie
he had a child's handwriting okay
yeah he could write eloquent words and
stuff but you know
his handwriting was just really shitty
he wasn't that he wasn't like that he
was an orator
all right a good but he was kind of a
disciplinarian also with a military type
background and
very traditional conservative
the closest person to him in generation
and character
and time probably would have been james
brown that's what i was just gonna say
james brown was exactly like that from
the same [ __ ]
james brown uh he didn't stay in the
southern republican vein all the time
because he supported jfk
he would jump over to the democrat side
if he liked that candidate
but he was of the same mindset in the
south the democrats were clad
in that era republicans were unionist
they were the you know the party of
lincoln that's that's the way they saw
things
um when when um
but elvis and james brown got along they
were
real real similar when elvis died they
say james brown
when he james brown got invited to
graceland and he needed time along with
the casket when it was up and they say
he [ __ ] lost it
um i think part was because elvis died
young
i mean yeah he he was only 40 some yeah
and he was younger than i am now yeah
and he didn't look young when he died he
had
drug abuse problems that he couldn't
face up and i think there was like i
think he also said
he he hit male menopause too i think was
part of it
and uh but
brown lost it and uh they they were
evidently [ __ ]
they didn't hang out all the time
because they had busy schedules a lot
but they had a lot in common and they
were gonna
uh they were gonna make albums together
or songs and [ __ ] together
singles and things they never got around
to it though but elvis was when he died
he was
he was planning on making a recording
studio and he was going to have a lot of
people from
the gospel and and old school rock and
roll coming because
and and record uh whole albums
because he wanted a way to culturally
the culturally um he thought
respond to the british uh
new uh new wave in terms of you know
what i mean like the rolling stones and
all the beatles and everyone that came
in there they were taking over
so elvis and a lot of other guys wanted
to have like a
solid american response to all that and
they were
all trying to plan on building a
recording studio and in those days the
recording studio was millions of dollars
because the technology was expensive
yeah
dermott says michael jackson didn't even
pay his staff half the time
because he had no concept of real life
yeah yeah but i mean because for him
like the money was always there
right so he didn't have to think about
it and other people did [ __ ] for him
so and i think the same thing applied to
elvis to to a lesser extent
because if your whole entire life or
your whole entire adult life
everything is just done for you like
every you know
everybody is going before you like
paving the way like making things easier
for you
but you don't realize that because you
don't see other people's labor like all
the [ __ ] they have like all the strings
they have to pull like to
get it all together you know what i mean
i feel so i feel like that was something
that
this movie really did well was that you
know
honestly he wanted to go see the
president and at first like nixon was
like [ __ ] i don't want to do that
um because he wasn't and he's like i'm
not meeting some rock and roll guy it's
like what the [ __ ] it's this you know
so but all these like all the [ __ ] that
went up
went kind of on behind the scenes that
like his friends were doing
and i don't think elvis was entirely
aware of how much
you know his fame how much his friends
working behind the scenes like
made that happen you know what i'm
saying dom the bomb asked uh
you know how did elvis health get so bad
there had been whole books written about
that what happened to
us yeah i think it was a
i have a theory behind it some people
come well he had this weird disease
there's even a name for the damn disease
he felt bad
which he might have he may have had
fibromyalgia or
no i think what happened was he if i
remember correctly
he had an injury he fell and hurt a leg
and during the healing process it might
have been a leg
they prescribed him some um painkillers
that happens to people a lot
yeah and happened to someone i know as
well
i mean it it didn't last but someone i
know
he can't say who it painkillers
and felt bad and went back on the
painkillers
over a period of years he had kind of a
quack doctor that just kind of
kept [ __ ] prescribing him different
kinds of damn painkillers they're all
opium based painkillers you know
much like you're gonna get addicted if
you're famous yeah and you got money
then you can find a doctor that will
give you
whatever you want doctors most a lot of
doctors are just
they're legalized drug dealers really
they'll give you whatever you want
um and especially like doctors of the
stars they'll give you whatever you want
just ask michael jackson all right yeah
they'll keep you floating on air
well this happened in a time in elvis
life that was not good
he was beyond the age of 35 a man's
normal
testosterone production starts to
decline at that time
if you start taking opioids you'll
collapse
uh testosterone production it'll go down
to zero
if you come off that drug you'll feel
like [ __ ] and you'll really lose your
mojo
you just won't have any damn energy
which would encourage you to go back on
the drugs yeah you'll feel a little bit
better
but your testosterone is suppressed and
looking at him
he physically looks like somebody
doesn't produce any damn testosterone
he's fat and he's puffy
if you have his face with his face is
super super puffy
which tells me that [ __ ] he didn't
have any androgens in him
okay when your testosterone is real low
you'll be [ __ ] groggy
uh you won't have mental clarity
uh you'll have you will put on a lot of
fat
you won't be able to lose the fat you'll
burn muscle before you'll learn
burn fat when you don't have any test in
you
so that's what i think was wrong with
him they didn't know this kind of stuff
back then what he needed was he needed
detox
and he needed to be getting exogenous
hormone treatment
hrt hormone replacement therapy would
have knocked that weight back off of him
he would have felt a lot better
he would have felt real positive mental
um
mental attitude again he'd gone back
into his music and he he could have
continued
but it becomes a vicious cycle of
depression causes suppression
suppression causes depression just on
and on and on it feels like the hand of
death is coming at you
so he was taking those pills to hide
from that but
but like i said those pills will stop
testosterone production it won't
fix anything it'll just hide a symptom
you'll get fatter and fatter and
more lethargic and depressed and that's
what happened he died
tila said those banana peanut butter
bacon and jelly sandwiches didn't help
either i'm constipated just
thinking about it yeah well that's
another thing i i kind of feel like
they didn't have an understanding of
well and growing up in the south too i
kind of feel like there's kind of a
southern thing where
yeah food is religion well that's the
way that people express affection
because
they're not comfortable doing it in
other ways so it's it's kind of like
you know that's how they show you that
your family shows you they love you they
just
keep feeding you um you know what i mean
so i think there's that so when he felt
bummed out
he not only took drugs but ate yeah and
because that made him feel good
like for a short time the funny well the
funniest thing to me
about this movie is that he wanted to
he wanted to go undercover he's [ __ ]
elvis right and he wanted to go
undercover
yeah in like uh like hippie comedians
bands
the black panthers penetrate the black
panther i'm like
yeah okay i don't think that's gonna
work out the way you think but yeah so
he thought he was gonna do that and he
was gonna like infiltrate the drug
culture
yeah but by that point he was on like
all those opioids
but like i said i don't think that he
saw that as
drugs even though they absolutely are he
thought it was medicine
yeah it's like so he was like decrying
oh everybody like doing pot and lsd but
he was like a drug addict too but i
guess he didn't see it that way
yeah that's not the he didn't make that
mental leap
although i think a lot of people still
don't see it that way like i think like
prescription drugs or painkillers and
stuff they don't really see that as
in the same way that they would see like
crack
well those prescription opioids will
also kind of distort your thinking
they'll put you even further in a bubble
i don't think he had any idea he was
addicted to those things
it didn't seem like i don't think he had
any idea that those things affected him
yeah and um
well in the fact that he had a whole
entourage that was just willing to do
whatever he wanted well they tried to
take the pills from him and he pulled a
gun on
that's true yeah he was he was feeling
bad he took the gun he
he pulled that [ __ ] he says don't you
ever take medicine you're trying to take
my meds are you trying to kill me
yeah so you know what okay
although i think elvis if they'd had the
medical knowledge is that right
holy crap if they'd had the medical
knowledge
they'd known more about the androgen
system uh
i think a simple blood test would have
showed that he was [ __ ] starved out
for [ __ ] all kinds of
hormones and you could you could have
banged him up
pretty good got him feeling better
getting him off those damn pills
he'd felt a lot better you could keep
him on the pills as long as you were
[ __ ] pumped and pull a test he'd be
fine
because he doesn't need to produce his
own he would just be on testosterone and
high
but he'd still his body would have
worked a lot better
well like i said and here's another
thing
where was [ __ ] with him about how fat
he got i saw
pictures of him in like the final months
he was fat but he wasn't as fat as i
thought he got he's not as bad
he got chubby he was chubby but i gotta
hand it to elvis
when he was in the fat phase in his
final months i saw one as one of his
performances he sounded great
he became like a southern luciano
pavarotti he was doing
like [ __ ] operatic [ __ ]
opera level gospel music
he sounded great so his performances
never really suffered from what i saw
i'm sure there's a few bad ones but what
was recorded was
he was great yeah i didn't really notice
that he was getting slacked off in that
regard at all he just gave it
that's good he gave it his all when he
was on stage evidently oh yeah
tila said oh he was pretty sexy even
chubby
yeah it's like i don't know if i'd call
i know everybody says fat elvis but like
i said i don't know if i call him fat
fat he wasn't obese
i don't think he was chubby chunky yeah
that's all he had he gained weight and
that
i'm telling you that's opioids and
[ __ ] lack of testosterone
and lots of peanut butter and sandwiches
and and in this era dudes didn't work
out
you were supposed to be strong just by
your innate inner power
yeah it's almost like working out was
like cheating cheating
well of course you got big you you
lifted weights that's cheating
you're supposed to be strong just on the
back your own man you're supposed to
just do that through your will
just will yeah
look at [ __ ] charlene heston all
right he was physically large framed guy
but there was no meat on that dude
he's walking around his shirt off like
he's [ __ ] arnold
people didn't have any standards back
then they didn't know what well
yeah now the thing about it is that they
had chris reeves
that's true but he was like well he got
to play superman so
he was even like a cut above even back
then they didn't recognize
but well the thing about it is that this
is something that i think about a lot
of christmas steve reeves uh the dudes
that played the uh he played
hercules yeah yeah they had steve and
steve reeves well that was deer and hit
that was
charles and uh what's his face looking
great to uh
mickey hargitay who was married to um
yeah yeah what's her name
yeah uh [ __ ] steve reeves [ __ ] was
damn he was old he was almost not quite
as big as arnold but he was about the
same upside as arnold after arnold
stopped lifting yeah you know he looked
great
well and like you said it wasn't really
mainstreamed back then we kind of talked
about that a little bit on the
show that we did about bodybuilding it
wasn't really i think for a long time it
was almost kind of
seen as like a niche thing or like a gay
man thing
yeah you know what i mean well men under
men are very visual
it's the aesthetic quality it's of a lot
of straight guys of course they're being
they're going to be focusing on women
the aesthetic quality
looks like gay men are going to be
focusing on under the men so they're
going to pay attention to the to these
little details
and it'll all [ __ ] you know it's
obvious if a dude's [ __ ] looking good
you're not gonna get compliments from
women because they're gonna
think that that's [ __ ] they feel
threatened by that you know what i mean
they're gonna look but they're not gonna
say well not well because it's weird to
go up to a random dude if you go through
a dude and say you
then he might like you don't know what
he's going to do then yeah so yeah
but it's just not something that you do
but uh gay dudes will compliment the
[ __ ] out of you
yeah those guys compliment the [ __ ] well
like i said they don't have anything i
don't have any barriers behind it
like god you're handsome or bad you're
looking good and just you know
so so you know i do that to women you're
looking beautiful you know so
you know that's just it's just i'm just
saying that it's not so much like women
don't do that to men because it's a
completely different
different dynamic dynamic and you don't
like you don't know that dude he could
be a murderer um you know what i mean
you don't know anything about him
yeah so it's like the fact that you're
putting yourself in front of this dude
that you don't know
right and making a comment on his
appearance
that he's going to interpret as ooh this
chick is into me
is this dude gonna stalk me now is he
gonna let you know what i mean so
is he gonna follow me home like you
don't know what he's gonna do
right so you don't do that
you don't do that ever i mean
i would never dream of doing anything
like that because you don't know what
that dude's gonna do you don't know that
guy
did that to me no he did it
yeah you were flirting with me no what
happened was
you flirted with me from day one what
happened
to you i walked by you no the first
thing was that you
liked my necklace oh yeah you said that
was the first thing
i had seen you before but i didn't say
anything to you i wouldn't have done
that
i'm not so i'm shy i don't like walk up
to people like that you
i walked past you on the way out to the
front bar i remember okay and you said
something you i had a necklace i don't
remember what necklace was but you were
i wouldn't have come up and talked to
you like that randomly said that was
thick elvis
thicke elvis yeah with two c's
waste a lot of pavarotti but i'm gonna
tell you man well pavarotti was like
was pretty big though and fat dudes can
[ __ ] make
make some [ __ ] cool sounds they can
sing a lot of them
[Music]
especially in the classical type stuff
they have all that room to like
you know echoes i don't know that's what
it is i'm just making
it up but well yeah i don't know it's
it's just kind of like
what i was going to say before was that
it always interests me because
i feel like people didn't really know
much about
as you said fitness or nutrition or
anything like that it's like a lot of
the [ __ ] that they used to say
back in the 50s 60s [ __ ] like that were
you know we know now is probably
[ __ ] team
team mentions that she thought michael
jackson was sexy the thriller days
because he was very slim
so it depends on how you carry it yeah
that's true but you have to also look at
what happens to
guys of that build as they age most of
them don't
don't keep that that slim look what
happens to a lot of them is they get
like skinny fat
where they'll be skinny arms and legs
but then there's a got a [ __ ] belly
um and that's that's just because the
hormonal profiles
you just can't burn fat after 35 very
well
um it gets worse by the time your 50s
you're going to lose muscle before you
lose fat unless you're
very gifted um
that's what testosterone is for just
start bumping that you'll [ __ ] burn
it like you did when you're a [ __ ]
teenager
you leave greasy spots wherever you go
[ __ ] again get all [ __ ] slimy let
me make you another drink
yeah what's up is that collapsing what's
happening over that computer
oh it's crashing again crashing again it
does that all the time all right
i'm used to it at this point you want
the same thing
yeah okay i'll restart it it doesn't
need the only thing that i keep this
computer on for is for the
on air light it's not on otherwise
but it should be okay that i restarted
it but yeah this was something i thought
i was
thinking about the other day because i
watch a lot of um
real old movies like the 40s 50s 60s
and before they knew a lot about
fitness before they knew a lot about you
know
before they did a lot of plastic surgery
all the [ __ ] they do nowadays
so it kills me sometimes to think of all
the [ __ ]
that actors and stuff had to do
back in those days i mean i've heard
some horror stories about actresses back
in the 30s and 40s
that basically if they were you know had
a contract to a studio or whatever and
they weren't allowed to like gain
they were only allowed to gain this many
pounds or whatever and then they would
weigh you
and then if you like you know gain too
much weight they'd give you [ __ ]
speed
or they tell you like you couldn't eat
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so they
were doing that same kind of [ __ ] back
then but
i think they had less of a i think back
then it was either
starve or take speed yeah like for the
actresses because they didn't want you
getting fat you know
what cigarette what do you point that
cigarette
i think out of everybody we know there's
only two guys that were able to maintain
skinniness as they got older that would
have been aurora's husband
and mark from mark and laura
and some people and it's genetics they
eat like [ __ ] crazy well some of it
yeah i think a large to a large extent i
think some of it is genetic some people
can just eat and eat and not gain i mean
my grandmother was like that
she was a tiny tiny woman i think she
weighed maybe 90 pounds her entire life
and then when she got you know older
like in her 70s because she died when
she was 79.
she got into her late 60s and 70s she
maybe
gained 10 pounds so she maybe weighed
100 100 110 pounds maybe
um and she ate whatever she wanted drank
cokes
every day she never drank water she only
drank coca-cola
she ate little debbies she had all that
fattening southern food
never gained an ounce actually she said
when she was younger
they used to try to make her gain weight
because she was underweight
she's like and i remember they used to
make me drink beer with every meal they
used to like feed me milkshakes and it's
just it never did anything
she never gained any weight she was tiny
tiny tiny her whole life
and i was just i used to tell her
because i used to tease her all the time
i
say man i wish i'd got those jeans nope
i've been studying the human
results of human experimentation over
the past two years
of diet and exercise for [ __ ] men
as they age after 40 and um
and some guys can remain skinny like
that
like forever we were talking about but
that's that's genetics
yeah you can't do that all right most
people don't have those genes
yeah that's like that's like winning the
lottery for the average
person the best strategy
is one that i have said many time on
this show
growth growth
if you can keep your body in a state
of growth or building
you can do what's called you can re you
you can keep a decent body composition
where you eat a high protein diet low in
carbohydrates
low in calories weight lifting
and you want to balance your hormones
you want to have
the hormones of a person in their 20s or
30s which you get through an hrt clinic
that means that your body will respond
properly
to those workouts that you do i was able
to [ __ ] lift
for the first two years and make some
progress
but man i maxed out and then it just
became constant pain and [ __ ]
soreness and achy just never really heal
up there's just too much
muscle fiber there to heal with the
hormonal profile that i had put the
hormones in there and all of a sudden
healing is no problem you feel better
you can continue to grow
you don't have to grow big just keep
yourself
bumping yourself up over the your last
20 or 30 years until you die
and you'll look and feel a lot better
during that
growth period because when you're
growing you're healing
and you're maintaining if you're not
doing anything it starts to atrophy
you don't you want to prevent atrophy
aging and dying is a form of atrophy so
you don't want to be in
atrophy mode you want to be in growth
mode
you're going to need hormones to do it
probably though because you're
genetically programmed to die that's why
the hormones are stopping you don't need
you're out of the you're out of the
reproduction game nature's trying to get
you the [ __ ] out of here
but why the [ __ ] do you want to listen
to nature nature says your teeth fall
out
when you're not gonna put false teeth in
nature says you blind you're not gonna
put contacts in
nature says your [ __ ] hair's falling
out you're not gonna put a [ __ ] wig
on
or you're just gonna shave it all up be
bald right one or two
it's just there's ways to combat all
this stuff
if something's missing replace it that's
all
yeah 60s room is saying that's what they
did to judy garland that's exactly who i
was thinking of like a couple of people
brought her up
and i feel like bill because if you see
wizard of oz um
she's not fat and she's just like normal
sized
but i think that what happened was that
they were like well you need to get
thinner and so they started like feeding
her speed and i think she got addicted
to it and then that's
uh started on the downward spiral
because they were giving her all the
drugs to keep her thin
and i think that happened to a lot of
starlets particularly
in those days um i was in the days where
being skinny was being pretty
yeah exactly so they just kept look they
just kept feeding them drugs all the
time
to keep them from getting fat yeah and
and that's the worst thing you can do to
a woman as she ages
it's the worst that's the worst thing
you could do to anybody is to keep a
person in a state of starvation
especially as they age now there's some
bodies that are built for that
to be thin it's all over china and japan
but most people are not supposed to be
like that most people are kind of
supposed to fill out well you're not
supposed to be in starvation mode but it
does it is actually better to be in
calorie restriction um well that depends
on your hormonal profile
well and depending on like uh you know
it prevents like a lot of diseases and
stuff like that um there's a whole
science to this
on my instagram i got women on there as
examples of
watching their progress men's progress
through all these different age
different age groups i know what they're
taking i know what their
work workout routines are um
there are women like lauren lopez in
their mid 50s
that do hormone replacement they do
light cycles of anabolics
and they lift and at 50 something just
gorgeous
gorgeous and do they look
older yeah they look older they don't
look like a skinny little 14 50 year old
girl they
they look like a woman you know it's
because she's keeping her body in a
state of growth
and that growing is maintaining
all of the entire body include including
circulatory systems and
you know respiratory systems and uh
evidently people that do it this way
also have a less chance of cancer
very rarely do they come down with any
kind of cancers because growth
also combats cancer
so you end up being having a metabolism
like a shark you know
they were a [ __ ] turtle you know they
never really die
they just continue to slowly grow you
know the alligator just gets bigger and
bigger and bigger
bigger you just don't want to get so big
to where you max out
and then that's a lot of stress on your
body too you want to grow kind of slowly
you know over 20 or 30 year period that
way it's
incremental improvements and refreshing
and rebuilding the body
uh you might need outside help like i
said
hrt that's the first step
i'm doing i mentioned i saw results
instantly
as soon as i got got those hormones
bounced
she felt like i was starving for
something it was like a lot of
satisfaction like oh man i
forgot what this felt like just
everything's working well
now i could eat eat all day i just
affected fat just coming off
everything works like it did when i was
in my twenties
is there a risk
at the dosages that i'm doing now not
really
because it's just a normal level for a
healthy person in their 20s or 30s maybe
20s so i'm just putting back stuff in
there that's supposed to be in there
if it shaves a couple years off the end
of my life which i doubt it but if it
did
it'd be worth the trade off you'd die
anyway why not [ __ ] have
a good quality second half of your life
you know what i mean
then to have a long shitty one where's
the qualities
you know two years i got extra two years
it was shitty but you know
it's better just to go ahead and just
[ __ ] just do it
it's gonna be good it's gonna work out
strongly 78 says i can think of a ton of
women celebrities that look like they
age well the dudes not so much
um yeah and tila made the point there's
more pressure on female celebrities and
i think that female celebrities there's
a lot less
um stigma about them getting plastic
surgery as well i think dudes do but i
don't think it's quite
as i don't want to say acceptable
because it is but
i don't know i feel like women are a lot
more it depends on who it is but i think
it's a lot more
um each celebrity said different things
and then dermott says 90s were worse
with the heroin chic look yeah i
remember that
everybody wanted to look like they were
starving to death
each one of those celebrities men's
celebrities is a different
is a unique situation a good example
would be sylvester stallone
sylvester stallone's like 74. he's
starting to show
signs of age but he looked great at 63.
he looked great all right now he had
[ __ ] his face up
you can see it in was it rambo four it
looked real [ __ ] fun
with all the gore yeah yeah that's a
good movie though
i didn't really i was looking at all the
heads exploding basically
real [ __ ] up and the reason why that
happened is because
stallone started to mess around with
human growth hormone
which for a while they thought that
might have been
something safer and better to use than
some kind of a
anabolic steroid
it does it does do a pretty good job but
one of the things it does it makes your
[ __ ] nose and your face
if your facial features grow when you
have to have all this [ __ ] trimmed back
down you gotta have your face redone
so people stopped using it or at least
yeah because that seems like
yeah it didn't that's a big downside
well my body looks skinny but my face is
enormous well it didn't make him look
skinny it was he was trying to build up
a bunch of bulk without
[ __ ] his heart up on steroids
now people will go these steroids [ __ ]
up your heart and this and that
um all right a lot of guys in the 1970s
guys like
arnold and the guys from the golden era
a lot of them died okay because they
were taking oral st
steroids and real primitive steroids
from that time
and they were taking them in tremendous
amounts
a competition bodybuilder going through
uh what do you call it but going through
the olympia
they're one they already have [ __ ]
great
genetics they can get big thank you
david by the way
it says because no one sent anything for
her thank
they already got great genetics they
work out like [ __ ] crazy they're
already got pretty big skeletons most of
them
and then they take a [ __ ] ton of
steroids to maxing it out
they're like guys drag racing to see who
can get biggest the fastest
they're trying to make that show date
that's super hard on your system
they're young doing this too so they're
just burning themselves up by the time
they're [ __ ]
you know they're in their 20s and late
teens arnold was taking [ __ ] like 16 and
17.
he's [ __ ] banging [ __ ] heavy
steroid cycles arnold's [ __ ] huge man
by the time he was 19 he was giant that
takes a lot of gas out of your tank
it does it [ __ ] his heart up by the
time he was 50 he couldn't do that
anymore he'd kill himself
so you have to move on to other things
and if you don't you're going to [ __ ]
lose all that mass and they didn't
really have hrt or [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] testosterone and there's only so
much of that you can take you know
so guys like stallone started to mess
around things like hgh because that
doesn't quite
do the same thing as steroids does but
it [ __ ] his face up
but he held out real good till 60
something
73 you start c he's he's showing signs
of age
but he looks much better than most
people at 73 i mean he looks a lot
better than most people at 70. well [ __ ]
man i see movies from a long time ago
that had actors in it that were supposed
to be in their 20s or 30s but it looked
like they were about 50 years old
but then you find out later that that
actor was like 28 and i was like holy
[ __ ] crap that is a hard 28.
yeah i'm not i'm not a doctor i'm you
know i'm not giving medical advice
i'm just telling you what i've been
seeing
you don't want to mess with any of that
[ __ ] until you're until you're
middle-aged and if you do it middle-aged
you want to be prescribed things by
doctors
and everything's got to be stuff that's
in the safer categories and it all has
to be in reasonable doses
because when it look when you look at
guys who've actually done things
and lived an entire life and died in
their 80s or 90s
you start to see a pattern guys like
jack lalanne
they didn't do anything until they were
in the latter half of their life and
then they kept it kind of reasonable and
they looked great and they were strong
and they die in their 80s their 90s but
when they die they look strong
they are strong they're healthy in
certain ways something's going to get
you somewhere
you know what i mean and something
eventually does get them
but it's not the drugs you know what i
mean those compounds actually
strengthened them
without that they may have died sooner
you just don't know
but you know we're you're all gonna
everybody's gonna die anyway
it's only a matter of time i'm not i'm
just kidding
i know no i am um i'm just kidding
no we got a uh hello from luxembourg and
look their screen name is i believe
harry [ __ ] we're getting but not
spelled the way we're getting crazier
and crazy
i mean unless that's your real name let
me check all the
much canada says uh talking about
intermittent fasting
i try to do that too um where it's kind
of like every day
you can there's only like an eight-hour
window in which you can eat and then
after that eight hour window is over
like you have like 14 or 16 hours where
you can't eat
yeah i try to do that too but it's
you know it depends we have literally
eaten one thing today well i've only
literally
i don't know if you ate something else
while i wasn't looking because i was in
your world
yeah we had a little bowl of spaghetti
meatballs about that big
and that's all yeah well it all depends
while you're i had that and i had a cup
of coffee
this morning that's all yeah it all
depends on what you're trying to fiber
if you're trying to lose fat but
maintain your muscle mass
it's tough especially if you're older
okay you're more likely to lose muscle
mass and keep the fat if you're older
just just the hormones aren't there if
um
if you're young or gifted genetically or
both
and you're on things like hrt or things
like clicking anabolic steroids
you can pretty much eat anything you'll
just burn it up
you'll gain a whole bunch of [ __ ]
muscle mass
if you're if you're lifting though you
just can't sit there and take that [ __ ]
if you just sit there and take that [ __ ]
you'll just turn into a [ __ ] big blob
you'll look bloated as hell that stuff
allows you to heal up quickly so you can
work out every day instead of
twice a week you're working out every
[ __ ] day 12 hours later you're fully
healed up you go in there and you
[ __ ] work out again
super humans [ __ ] strengthen
endurance
super human healing abilities some of
that's just dangerous though depends on
what it is each one of those compounds
has different effects some of them will
turn you into a total psycho
like trend balloon trend blown will make
you kill some [ __ ] it makes you [ __ ]
evil
uh it's a very effective uh just
don't [ __ ] with that i'm good that's it
there's all i don't need that
it'll burn every ounce of fat off you
and make you a [ __ ] i mean that
sounds something out of a god oh yeah
it'll happen fast you'll just be ripped
you'll get [ __ ] huge
and you'll be i don't know being evil
might be worth it i'm already kind of
evil it's just i just keep it under
wraps
turn you into a total [ __ ] psychotic
psychopath
it's like [ __ ] uh when they take it
they'll also take like mood stabilizers
along with it and should try to
counteract all those um side effects a
lot of stuff isn't like a one-shot deal
it's a whole stack of stuff you got to
take this that and this and that and
this and that
it's all counteracting one another and
then if they raise the dosages sometimes
they gotta [ __ ] raise
it's just a huge bottle of [ __ ] but
these are guys who are doing competition
bodybuilding they're
almost like professional drug addicts
and they
it's a whole bunch of [ __ ] and that's
why a lot of them [ __ ]
die a lot of them die dude named rich
piana he looked like a [ __ ]
freakazoid look
he looked like that dude out of that
marvel superhero movie
thanatos what's his name with thanos
that he he looked just like
that he didn't it didn't look like a
human just
huge shoulders the size of bowling balls
big old [ __ ] arms and everything
he was a nice guy he made a lot of money
selling stuff off the internet but
he was famous instagram stuff died of a
heart attack
i mean it's just the human heart is not
designed
to move that much mass around you know
if his heart was maybe three times that
size he could power a body that size but
he just died
you know just it's just too much goddamn
mass
you're just genetically not designed to
carry i mean your heart's only this it's
only that big
yeah he got huge huge and i don't think
aesthetic really he didn't think he
looked good but you know what's really
weird
um you know since we're talking about
that
and in the opposite direction because
many years ago
like right right around the time that i
met you or started hanging out with you
yeah i lost like 90 100 pounds
yeah and an interesting and it took
maybe five months
right i lost it like fairly quickly i
wasn't starving
but i was going on like severe calorie
restriction
an interesting thing that happened i
felt a lot better it was like a lot
energy a lot more energetic and stuff
like that but an interesting thing that
happened was i started to develop
heart palpitations yeah and i started
passing out all the time
a lot of people did that yeah and i even
ended up i went to a cardiologist he
hung me upside down on a table
well because it first happened like i
went to give blood
because i used to have to you know i had
to monitor my cholesterol because it
used to be high it's not anymore
and um and i passed out and i had a um
seizure like on the floor so then they
started sending me to all this [ __ ]
and so the doctor says to me it's like
your heartbeat is very weird it's like
your heartbeat
every time it every time you breathe it
like speeds up so it's like not even
you know what i mean yeah so it's like
you know so it's like
like it's like that so then i had to
like wear a heart monitor for a long
time so they could like check it out
they said well there's probably nothing
wrong
but you might want to watch that you
know what i mean
but i think maybe what it was and the
doctor said this too
because i told him i said well i just
lost like 90 or 100 pounds like in
a five six month period and he's like
well that might be what it is because
your body is so used to pumping blood
around
an extra 900 pounds and now that's not
there anymore
and so it's making you feel weird or
lightheaded like your heart can't
regulate like your [ __ ] anymore
she was super skinny looking when we
first started to go out it actually
didn't look that good you look better
when you gain some of that back
yeah you're too skinny yeah i got down
to like pretty skinny yeah
i wasn't anorexic i was 118. that was a
lot
way way too and that was uh even now i
see pictures of myself when i was 118
and i'm like cool
yeah i looked kind of ill a lot of
people you looked better at around 130
140.
and yeah and my heart was like freaking
out back then too
yeah somebody was in there saying that i
was some girl was in that thing that
might have been
standard sandra said that she was too
thin for me yeah i don't really like
there are some there are some women that
look good did
but i i like curves really you know
yeah it depends on the person i mean
everybody has yeah everybody has their
own thing going on yeah
um so if you can like rock
what you got and it looks good like with
what your whole
situation is yeah then you know
but i like calling out all this second
chemical stuff
and [ __ ] metabolic stuff and drugs
because i know that
instagram is a big thing a lot of people
will a lot of people follow people in
the in the new version of the fitness
scene
because these people are all selling
stuff and they put up pictures of
themselves they get a lot of followers
people go boy i wish i could look like
that and that's telling you
every pretty much every one of those
fitness girls and guys
they're all on something all right
they're not going to tell you that
because they're trying to sell you some
kind of a powder
or some kind of a shirt or something and
the stigma is still kind of there
but a person with an amazing
physique is on something the reason why
it's amazing
is because it's on the outer edge of
normal and to be on the outer edge of
normal
or in the abnormal era area
you have to be on something just the way
it is the human body isn't built to look
like that
yeah you don't really see any of that
happening naturally no i mean that would
be
very it'd be one in a billion and it
would be genetic if it looked like that
naturally
and there's not enough of those genes
out there in the gene pool to rise to
the top it would be a freak man
a freak expression of some kind of a
gene usually
the people that you notice there's
usually something unusual about them
all right that's why you noticed them if
they were normal you wouldn't notice
them
so if they look abnormally good looking
they're on something
they're also working they're working out
but they're on some
especially if they're older i mean it's
easy for
a teenager or a person in their 20s
to get kind of an extreme physique but
they won't keep it for long
their hormonal profiles yeah i mean when
you're in your like teens or 20s
especially if you're a guy
yeah um because [ __ ] i i have brothers i
you know and i had a lot of male friends
growing up it's like those [ __ ]
could eat everything yeah
that wasn't nailed down yeah and just
not getting any weight
yeah it's the hormonal profiles
meanwhile me as soon as i went through
puberty
i started gaining weight every time like
i sniffed food
yeah so you know
[Laughter]
so i'm just a little resentful no not me
yeah oh
pokey but right sweetie right now
depending on what this i don't know what
state you're in but in the state of
florida
the safest most approved thing you can
do is hrt which is hormone replacement
therapy
yeah you're gonna jump up here um
you can also there are also men's health
clinics around here that'll straight up
[ __ ] give you hrt
androids that's legal here
um in florida
but i think there's like certain waivers
i haven't looked into that but
i think there's certain waivers to that
um and they're probably gonna be limits
to how much they can give you
because they're not you know what i mean
they're not gonna be giving you what
well they don't want to go they don't
want to get sued so they're gonna give
you something right that happens where
pro
is bodybuilders gonna be taken you know
pretty much all that stuff is relatively
safe nowadays
that what they're using as long as it's
in reasonable
dosages but supervised by a doctor
don't go out there and just i've had
some people contact me on there and ask
me all kinds of questions on the
internet about this and that
and then they can't repeat to me what i
just told them so i know a person like
that cannot handle a [ __ ] drug
schedule
all right it's a package of things you
had to take all the time well i don't
want this and i just want to and then
you go this is what's going to happen
that's going to shut down and you're
going to be able to bust nuts
that's what's going to happen because
they don't listen people think that
there's just a one-shot deal i'll just
take this and it'll be okay nah it's
usually three or four well people like
easy things yeah it's not easy
people like easy solutions and then
you're gonna be you're gonna need like
regular blood work once every four
months you're gonna have your [ __ ]
blood drawn and they have to look in
there and see if it needs to be adjusted
so it's a science to it it's proven
it's all part of life extension
everything is life extension brushing
your teeth is life extension
you don't brush your teeth you're gonna
lose your teeth you're gonna look like
[ __ ]
and in the wild you wouldn't be able to
eat you'd die okay
wiping your ass is bro okay
if you don't wipe your ass you're gonna
get an infection and then you're gonna
die
everyone's gonna say you're gonna get an
infection if your teeth fall out too
yeah that's right yeah if you don't have
no doubt and you start getting up in
somebody's ass crack and a booty crack
and haven't been wiping you're gonna
[ __ ] die
all right everything not eating ass it's
like
everything is live it sticks okay
hygiene
used to be the used to be that people
shut they [ __ ] in a pot and put the pot
underneath the damn bed
and recently yeah yeah that wasn't
really that long ago yeah
that shouldn't kill you we're talking
about i'm talking about
i read a book about the [ __ ] yeah
lizzie borden case right he said wash
your ass
yes wash your hands i mean that
shouldn't even said i'm just saying
um but yeah so i i remember this very
vividly
when i was a teenager in my 20s maybe i
read a book about the lizzie borden case
and one of the things that pretty much
the only thing that i remember from that
book
really vividly was that the whole family
they had eaten some bad mutton or some
[ __ ] like that
and they'd all been violently ill so
they'd all been like [ __ ] and
vomiting
into their [ __ ] uh you know chamber
pots
and that [ __ ] was still in the house it
was like under the beds
i'm like what you want to [ __ ] and vomit
in a bowl
and keep it like right over like under
where you sleep
did that not occur to you that that was
like not a good idea
that blows my [ __ ] mind it really
does
that blows my mind the fact that you
wouldn't even think of that and
um i think i might have brought this up
before but if you guys are like into
non-fiction or you know like
weird gross history or anything like
that there's this book called i can't
remember who wrote it but there's a book
called the ghost map
and it was about the cholera
i think it was the cholera epidemic in
london in the late 19th century
and that was how they discovered that
people
[ __ ] in the water supply
was what was causing cholera and like
the doctor that figured it out
they essentially were like which they
thought he was like a witch doctor
because they were just kind of like
that's not what's happened like we've
been [ __ ] in the water for
hundreds of years yeah that won't hurt
you fine that won't hurt you so
the fact that water's fine here's
hitting this water object switzerland
water there's no problem don't be such a
[ __ ] yeah
but it's like yeah it was like that and
it was just it's [ __ ]
mind-boggling it's mind-boggling because
i feel like
natural selection okay has
and i hate to like attribute you know i
don't want to give like
intention to natural selection because
it's indifferent but natural selection
has given animals not just humans but
animals mammals
the understanding that [ __ ] smells bad
and is gross
because you're supposed to avoid it yeah
so
the fact that people would be fine
with just [ __ ] in a puddle next to
their house and then just drinking the
water that was just
right there yeah and they didn't really
think anything of it and they didn't
think that was going to cause any
diseases
and the fact that somebody would come
forward and be like hey this might be
what's causing the problem and
everyone's just being like no
yeah and it's just it's the craziest
[ __ ] [ __ ] ever yeah people are really
really stupid recently
i i'm i'm on i'm watching youtube and
i'm
seeing all these [ __ ] videos and
everything on the news about all these
[ __ ]
intersectionalists and all these [ __ ]
this [ __ ] coming out of these
universities about all their [ __ ]
race theory and and i'm [ __ ]
realizing what are these [ __ ]
complaining about
think about it
just less than a hundred years ago
1890s we still hadn't
we still had barely kind of come online
with what the romans what the ancient
romans knew
at least at least like the elites you
know
[ __ ] in a way the late 1800s
philosophically kind of mentally if you
talk to the average person they were
kind of beneath the level of an ancient
roman
in their understanding of things a lot
of stuff has been lost from the roman
period
we're not even really sure what their
technology was there's
when they dug up when they when they uh
unearthed those two ships down there
that were mostly calligulous pleasure
barges
there was a central heating system in
those ships
that had valves valve works and castings
like of lion heads and stuff that was
gorgeous
we couldn't do things like that until
the 20s in some cases
well i think that's kind of why i mean
this is why people like me
that read about [ __ ] like that this is
why
i complain about [ __ ] nowadays because
i'm like we should be a lot farther
along
then yes we should be two thousand years
ahead i mean
i people disappoint me right that's why
very much
people are just disappointed the reason
why i mentioned this i was saying
it's kind of a travesty to try to judge
the way people and the way the united
states was in the 1800s
versus now because really the 1800s was
so
backwards compared to now i mean rome
was a little bit ahead of it in some
ways
it was just another [ __ ] world you
could not their thinking back then even
in the 1800s just was not
their understanding of reality was very
different than ours
yeah they had some good authors yeah
they had some good thinkers but those
were kind of like the elites
those were the top yeah i mean the thing
about it is that when you read because i
read some [ __ ] from back then
like fiction and various other things
some of the [ __ ] that you read
is almost like it could have been
written today yeah you know what i mean
um
but the world they lived in was not
today though no it's
it was a lot different it's a lot
different it was it and like i said
in some ways if you were to give me a
choice would you like to live in boston
in 1850 or would you rather live in the
city of rome
in [ __ ] the in in the year [ __ ] 20
a.d
or 80 bc i'd probably take 80 bc
or 20 a.d i could learn that language
portuguese and and and portuguese
descended from latin
i could learn that language i can read
that language a lot of languages
descended from latin
spanish french yeah i can read it
italian i can't understand all the nouns
because i don't know what they're
referring to they're referring to things
that i've never heard or don't exist
anymore
but i could easily learn that language
and yeah they had a lot of bad [ __ ]
going on there too
but it was a lot less repressive as long
as you weren't some kind of a german
slave you could probably have a lot of
fun there i mean
most people were in slavery yeah and
and i kind of feel like i don't know i
feel like this is kind of a question
that people said you know i
no one's invented a time machine yet but
if somebody came up to me and asked me
you know you can go to any year in the
past i
i don't think i would want to do that
yeah maybe because i'm a girl
and i'm just kind of like other would
have been cool [ __ ] probably
certainly i don't know man ancient egypt
probably been pretty good for a woman if
you had money
um no i don't have money though
well if you went back you could make
money maybe because you're modern
modern intel yeah i'd go back and i'd be
like the ancient egyptian nostradamus
yeah you should know what you do is you
show them how to make a thing like a
battery
or uh show them how to make things he's
like gather around
ancient peoples i'm gonna think of the
fashion designs you could cook
they probably love that [ __ ] i'm gonna
go change the entire course of history
i'm gonna [ __ ] everything
[ __ ] everything up i'm gonna [ __ ] i
was just gonna be i'm gonna butterfly
affect the
[ __ ] out of that i was just watching a
show though that had that had
roman or historians that were
specialized in ancient rome
and they were admitting how little they
actually know about the period they
don't really know what the level of
technology was
things are referred there they don't
know exactly what they're talking about
it may have been more like it wasn't
industrial
but close it was you know i mean it was
on the verge of an industrial revolution
as far as they know they they didn't
have internal combustion
they know that but they had something
called greek fire
and and they'd had that for centuries
but it it
but it's it was top secret the recipe
would never
was never passed down but some of those
guys
space lasers that greek death rays back
then the
death race the aliens showed it some of
those guys thought that maybe they did
have some
primitive uh understanding of electric
batteries
and maybe you know it's not crazy
about hydraulics it is a natural
principle and it's not crazy to think
that maybe somebody back then stumbled
across the [ __ ] yeah right
yeah i mean they think that the ancient
people did figure out batteries at least
at least in like limited pockets of
places right one guy thought that would
probably would have been kind of
pretty close to what you'd find in the
20s in europe
that at rome's height it might have been
something like that
you know not with radio but you know i
don't remember when marconi winter mark
going to do it said
20s right i thought it was earlier than
that but maybe a little bit earlier but
i don't remember
yeah then victor garcia talk about the
baghdad batteries yeah nobody knows
those are
those actually are batteries but boy
they sure do look like batteries they do
actually um i feel like maybe we should
do i was thinking about this the other
day and i forgot to write it down
but i thought maybe one of these days we
should do a show on uh
what do they call it oops like the out
of the out of time inventions
you know what i mean like that mechanism
thing they found like the baghdad
battery like other
other things like that yeah that where
they found things that looked like
kind of modern [ __ ] before they were
invented you know what i'm saying
they said there seemed to be mass
production
in in ancient rome they found things
that seemed to be standardized
but still little of it has has survived
yeah yeah well that's the thing too
is that you have to think it was such a
long time ago
one two only a very limited amount of
people were writing
about the time period yeah that's that's
the second thing
third thing it's like even if even of
all the people that were writing in the
time period
we don't necessarily know if we have all
of their writings if all the writings
have survived to the present day
so that's three things that's three
strikes right there
so we don't like actually know how much
[ __ ] were me i mean there
there's probably like huge segments of
history that's missing
victor brings up a good [ __ ] point
when they found that sunken roman ship
it was full of bitcoins
[Laughter]
oh my god yeah these will be worth a lot
of money someday
yeah garcia saying yeah i'd rather live
in pompei in 79
79 a.d that's what that [ __ ] blew what
well yeah that's kind of the point that
he was making yeah he's like yeah i
don't
you know you get bloom and maniac says
i'd take roman any year over boston in a
year yeah
i don't know i don't know yeah i just
don't know
let me go get a drink i wouldn't mind
like visiting some places
just to kind of see the [ __ ] but if
somebody told me how to stay there
um no thanks no thanks
um you know i like plumbing
and electricity you know what i mean
call me soft if you wish i want toilets
and running water
and air conditioning and internet's nice
too
although i lived a long time without it
i could probably live without that
but other than that yeah i don't really
want
i don't really want to live in a time
where people just threw their poop out
the windows
you know what i'm saying i don't like
that not one bit
ugh yeah and another point because we
don't realize how much wars destroy
history too and it's like yeah that's
what i mean it's like we don't even know
so much [ __ ] that happens is lost
because did anybody think to write it
down
if they did write it down do we still
have it nowadays
look at all the [ __ ] that's been lost
it's just [ __ ]
i don't know it's depressing to think
about sometimes
when you think about all the [ __ ] that's
happened how long it's been
and how much of that knowledge is gone
another thing that's kind of spooky is
that how
quick how short-lived civilizations tend
to be
that's you i mean it seems like a long
time to us but you know what i mean it's
like the human lifespan is
not really that not very long like uh
if you look at world history you'll have
like a civilization pop up and it'll be
around for a couple hundred years and
then it
goes back into a dark age something else
might pop up somewhere else and it's
only last for a couple hundred years
maybe [ __ ] thousand years or
something you know or
and it just kind of like popcorn popping
up and down you know
yeah well it didn't seem like that to
them because that was several
generations yeah yeah
you know what i mean but when you look
at it hi
advanced civilizations if you look at
through history
one that didn't get very advanced too
they didn't last very long
they did it for the people that lived in
them but
yeah and victor points out the spanish
burned the aztec and inca libraries
yeah that was second that was stuck in
the crime
and even the damn friars that were there
um wrote back to rome the vatican
and said we shouldn't be burning this
[ __ ] up man we need to keep all this
[ __ ] for posterity
historians are going to want to know all
this stuff they said no burn it all it's
all satanic
and you know these are guys in rome that
didn't even see this [ __ ]
i can understand why they thought that
way from their point of view you know
this is uh 1500s and
uh the mayan and aztec religions [ __ ]
would have looked like satanism to to
everything looked like satanism
let's be honest human sacrifice child
sacrifice
bless you sure that's not good i'm not
saying that but it's just kind of like
it's just
writing cortez cortez wrote about it
though
he what he describes was a totalitarian
theocracy
uh the ruling the ruling royal families
and the priests
inside what is it teotihuacan uh
teotihlan i remember the
remember with the name of the [ __ ]
capital city was
they used the threat of execution
over um noble men's families
in the servant cities in other words
they had made an empire of other cities
around it
they kept it in line because at any
moment
they could demand that that king over in
that
other city give up his daughter or his
son for sacrifice
so it was totalitarianism it wasn't a
free system
and that was one of the reasons why um
cortez was able to
[ __ ] people think that the spanish
just showed up and [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
up no
cortez showed up and he uh did a tour
around all the
cities for several years talking to
everybody and understanding the politics
and once he understood the system he got
a huge volunteer
allied army of all these allied indians
from the other cities
to overthrow the capital city and once
that happened a lot of the a lot of them
actually tore down their own religious
monuments
because they were trying to get rid of
an old system see
in the same way people were tearing down
nazi
uh uh monuments and soviet monuments
after the fall of the soviet union it's
just a common practice
a lot of that roman stuff disappeared
all throughout inc
all throughout europe because once the
empire was gone the [ __ ] locals
[ __ ] were sick of that [ __ ] they tore
it down because they were
symbols of a of a past that they didn't
want anymore
yeah you can understand why they why
they would do that like they did it from
a grassroots standpoint you'd be like
yeah i won't look at this [ __ ] anymore
these are my oppressors i don't like
want to see it
right because we didn't build these
statues these aren't ours yeah
victor's saying the whole thing about
the aztec thinking cortez was
quetzalcoatl
coming back as a myth the spanish word
all that [ __ ] after that kind
yeah well the thing is is that
uh cortez knew their religion by then he
had an indian girlfriend
i think her name was malenke palenque i
think her name was you
already had a son on the way um
the spaniards were already kind of
mixing in with the indigenous population
they started that from day one um they
said the women were real good looking
you know so and you know that's another
thing
is uh history's been recast as like
oh these white colonizers coming and uh
killing all these indians yeah they
killed a lot of people
but they also kind of the the writings
of the time kind of always expressed
kind of like these big man crush
man crushes on the indians about how
good looking when they were they were
strong and brave people
that they were kind of at a disadvantage
because
guns really didn't work against him
everything was hand-to-hand combat with
bladed weapons or clubs and
uh that they were better at field craft
i mean that's just mentioned over and
over again and they were all
marrying in with indians and had indian
children
that they were raising and you know most
of salem was
indian you know during the salem witch
trials that that's another thing you
know
about half of them have had married
indians
so it's just uh
it it wasn't it wasn't it
it wasn't just cut and dried you know i
mean people did
what are you looking for nothing i was
just uh oh okay looking at how much
drink you have left
i got a lot what you want another one in
a minute okay
in a minute let me get a cigarette okay
i was just laughing because uh
on a different topic dj maniac said
something that made me laugh
he said that well let's scroll back up
he said i'm in a war with some idiot on
facebook
right now because he claimed industrial
originated from new metal
and now i want to punch people
[Laughter]
and then he said later i told him he
probably thought green day invented punk
too
didn't shut him up though now he's
talking more [ __ ]
i think it came from actually house we
need to get like get into that a little
bit
when i was hanging out city club in
detroit and stuff saint andrews hall
i saw a lot of industrial bands one of
them was skinny puppy they were just
from across the river
the other one was called kitty with a
whip
that was a weird band they're gone now
kitten with a whip was a movie
yeah yeah see the kitten with the whip
or kitty with a whip well kitten with a
whip was the movie it had anne martin
come out
and john forsyth because i saw it on
mystery side
well in those same clubs some nights
were house it was like house and techno
and some of it was kind of like black
djs and some of it was white djs
skinny puppy and kitten with a whip
then the industrial stuff in detroit at
least
was kind of like the of the white
version of house
that's what it seemed like same clubs
same basic style
and it was and it was a goth version of
of house that's the best way i can
describe it i think that's where it came
from
it was inspired by djs doing things like
scratching and mixing and
mixing two songs together and then a guy
singing over it
and well that's kind of like the thing
that was happening in the rap scene with
public enemy
they were doing that same thing on the
street kind of like something you'd see
down in
jamaica where the bars were on the
street and they'd be playing
records out on the street and drinking
on the street selling cigarettes on the
street and then they start scratching
and singing over records and
they were do what they call that music
it was it's
it's not reggae um
it's jamaican have you ever heard of it
somebody in this comment section might
know
oh [ __ ] trying to remember what that
shit's called
well and you have somebody british might
know what that is you have to think too
that there was a lot of [ __ ] going on in
the 70s with
sort of experimental [ __ ] noise kind of
[ __ ]
you know stuff like throbbing gristle no
it wasn't
like that it wasn't dub and it wasn't
scar no one scoff
scott came from it
well scott was almost kind of like a
regular
punk hybrid yeah a little bit that's
all that's what it is thank you yeah
thank you donald got a dance hall
dancehall was kind of like a reggae
version of what public enemy was doing
here in the united states
that's just really funny to me because
i've heard you know what it's weird i
was thinking about this
today or yesterday because i was out on
my hike and i was listening to my
pandora station
and on the pandora station it played the
nine inch nails cover of dead souls the
joy division song
and for some reason i was thinking about
uh somebody i was talking to a really
long time ago
and they had gotten like really
insistent
that i don't know if it was that
particular song but they were really
insistent that like some cover of like
some really old song from the 70s
was the original and that the original
was the cover you know what i mean
but they were like a really young kid
yeah
and i it just made me laugh like how
certain they were even though they were
obviously wrong
yeah they didn't know they're talking
about um and it's just i don't know it
it was just kind of making me
making me laugh because i'm just kind of
like these kids that are like in their
[ __ ]
teens and twenties and they're just like
no ah like [ __ ] nine inch nails wrote
that song yeah i had a vegetarian i'm
like no that sound came out like 1979.
no no guys i answered or it was it was
dance hall
go check out dance hall dancehall is
kind of i believe where scott came from
and where a lot of reggae came from
and industrial when i first heard it
was kind of like detroit's version of
dancehall but it was for goth kids
rap had its own thing going on and then
there was another version of it called
techno
and techno was just
like a dance version of it dance club
version
of dancehall it's just it's difficult to
explain you know people
just make it up [ __ ] they're pulling
[ __ ] out their asses and the reason
that the genre is called industrial
initially i thought
was because the sounds were reminiscent
of
industrial noises factory noises and
so like i'm saying you're you have bands
like einsteins that don't know about and
for example which means collapsing new
buildings in case you didn't know
and they didn't have any musical
instruments they just
used pipes and masonry and things like
that to make the music
and that was going on i feel like late
70s early 80s at least
like the early [ __ ] was real noise
oriented yeah you know what i'm saying
so i don't know so so it's very funny to
me that like
younger kids that just kind of came on
the train as it was like at the at the
waist station like way along the line
yeah and then they
act like they know everything i was
getting okay i remember what i was
talking about i'm gonna answer the
question about
cortez cortez and the whole quetzalcoatl
or google con i think it was google con
uh mythos cortez had been there for
several years
getting ready for that big attack
against the uh
against the aztec capital city by that
time he knew the religion and the
culture
he already had indian allies from
kings and [ __ ] from the other cities
around it
he knew all about that quartet or that
um that kugel khan
mythos or or legend
so he planned some of his
contacts around the dates or
around the prophesied or around the
prophecy of kugacon
now i've heard one of the stories i
heard is that
his supposedly uh cortez's ships were
seen
on the day that cougar khan was supposed
to come back it sound that sounds
kind of iffy all right i think that was
a story that was made up later
anyway cortez made sure
that um that mont uh mont lord montezuma
believed that cortez may have been kugu
khan
and he fit the description of kugle khan
which um khan was a white man with a
mustache
and i guess a beard that came across the
ocean ron jeremy and ron jeremy
came across the ocean and taught them
about the calendar and the stars and how
to build stone buildings
and gave them the seeds of their
civilization
which sounds plausible that story was
much older than the aztecs
it could have been that's maybe some
phoenicians or
ancient greeks or something got blown
off course and ended up
somewhere down there in mesoamerica and
maybe the ship had passengers on it and
one of them may have given them some
information
and evidently kugu khan went got back on
the ship after he was
visiting them for years and went back to
his homeland and told them that he would
return
and they were waiting for kukukan to
return it
it had evidently been thousands of years
but they were waiting for him to return
so looks like uh cortez [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] tried to insert himself
into this legend
wish i would have done that you want to
use every advantage you can
it's like a psychology is very powerful
in any kind of conflict
well yeah man i mean you turn up in some
village
full of people who are probably hostile
towards you right
you kind of maybe want to take their
[ __ ] take over the [ __ ]
so you're just kind of like hey like
tell me all about your legends and tell
me about your gods and stuff like oh
yeah
i'm totally down with that and then you
just kind of insert yourself
people try to if you know what you're
doing people try to paint this image
that
uh the spaniards just showed up throwed
the [ __ ] out on the [ __ ] land and
[ __ ] pulled a gun and they owned the
place [ __ ] no
the first couple ships mutinied when
they saw the cities they were [ __ ]
bigger than anything in europe
like this is better than ours yeah yeah
they were all pinned in red
and turquoise and they had [ __ ] an
advanced society these were huge
metropolitan areas
this is what this these aren't this this
isn't little grass huts
and [ __ ] these were cities yeah they had
[ __ ] cities
millions of people and you're talking
about
70 80 guys per ship with some useless
[ __ ] barking sticks is what the
indians called them
the they were afraid of the barking
sticks but you couldn't do much damage
it took forever to [ __ ] reload those
things they were match locks
and you couldn't fight in the rain and
powder went bad
they impressed him with some cannons
they took some cannons off and showed
him some cannons
they tried to use the magic angle that
they knew magic
um so they were at least that savvy
yeah and they had never seen their
wizards
they'd never seen horses and they'd
never seen steel that impressed them
but the thing is they were vastly
outnumbered that [ __ ] wore off
they got their asses kicked and then in
the uh the night of tears
they did lose some battles they it did
eventually
what really got a lot of them was
[ __ ]
pandemic yeah the um the the
the spaniards were carrying [ __ ] the
plague all kind of diseases smallpox
you know it wasn't on purposes but it
was biased well yeah i mean
it's just nobody on this continent have
been started to that that we didn't have
any um
you know they didn't have any they
started dying of something made their
bubonic plague
bulbous the plague or
smallpox it's hard to tell what it is
they're talking about but they all
started dying and they thought it was
some kind of a
curse of the white man which i guess it
was well yeah technically yeah they
weren't wrong so they started to
depopulate
and then that spread up into the indians
they got the american indians so before
the first colonists ever got to north
america a lot of them were wiped out
uh there was an indian name squanto he
told
john smith yes told john smith all about
it he just got come back from india if
from england yeah
indians were in england before we ever
got here he comes back
and said he told smith that his tribe
had been wiped out in a big plague and
that most people were already dead
i just want to say that reminded me i
read this [ __ ] great book a few years
back
the hell was it called i think it was
called the speckled monster and it was
um or something like that the speckled
something right there
and it was um about smallpox
and how they found the vaccine for it
yeah
and it was a fascinating fascinating
[ __ ] book i wish i could remember who
read it
who wrote it i was like i said i was
really into
man my drink's empty yeah i guess yeah
oh you don't okay
um like i said i'm really into
uh history books that are about
the history of things you don't normally
think about the history of
if that makes any sense i really really
like these kind of like really little
niche history kind of books so yeah
there was one it
i can't remember i think it was called
the speckled monster i think i'd have to
look back at my goodreads
but it was all about how they found the
uh the vaccination
for smallpox and it was like it was
really really good that just like
i don't know him saying that like just
reminded me of it
um but yeah so
what were we talking oh yeah okay
so somebody said uh upward that they
were talking about when i was talking
about music and everybody thinking
like the the covers were the originals
and vice versa
and how they said that about johnny
cash's cover of hurt as well
i yeah i i think about that too because
johnny cash
also covered the mercy seat
by nick cave and i always want you know
i guess nick cave isn't really like a
young
person's thing like nine inch nails is
like you know back then
but that was something that always kind
of occurred to me that like maybe they
thought that
oh nick cave had covered the johnny cash
song even though it was the other way
around
i don't know i just thought it was like
really funny so deborah says like hey
guys just made it in from work
saw you guys were on yeah we've been on
for like two and a half hours so welcome
we're pretty drunk at this point
uh victor said the speckled monster i
just googled okay thank you i knew it
was the speckled something and i was
pretty sure that's what it was
but it was like a while back i just
checked it out of the library
and it was really really good as you can
see i'm super into
the history of diseases um
it's like just like i said niche
histories
history of diseases history of coffee
like
you know that book about salt what
like i said one of my favorite
nonfiction books that i ever read
was called the perfect red and it was
about
that dye that red dye that they used to
make from crunching up
uh you know the beetle shells and it was
it was a [ __ ] fascinating book
it was just kind of all about the trade
in the stuff and it like it
it made like a lot of um you know i mean
it was like really important to like a
lot of the trade
but you know back in the day and it's
just like so funny that something like
that that people don't think about
was so important at some time and it's
like that's just
i don't know that's just like really
fascinating to me
camp guy says pillars of the earth is a
great historical novel by ken fuller i
think i've read that actually
or at least i've read ooh
i feel like i've read that one but
didn't he write some other ones
like give me some other titles because i
feel like i've read
i'm pretty sure i read that one but i
might have read some other ones as well
uh victor says i watched a documentary
last night about the tulip bubble of
1637. yes see i've read a book about
that too
um it's kind of like
that cracks me up i feel like we should
do a show about that because
there was a thing if you guys don't know
you know how
back in the 90s or whenever it was when
everybody was convinced that like
uh for example like beanie babies were
gonna be and everybody was like
buying every single beanie baby and they
thought it was gonna be this big
collector's item
and then the value just [ __ ] crashed
okay the same thing happened
back then in the 1600s in holland with
different kinds of tulips
like did you hear me yelling yeah man
for some reason the ice maker isn't
making nice
what's the matter right i can't figure
it out
is the little bar thing not in the not
in the place
yeah figure it out i pulled it out i bet
that refrigerator is not that old
no i pulled the refrigerator out in case
the little water hose is kicked
maybe somebody pushed it down i don't
know i don't know i didn't push it
okay you pissed
that refrigerator is seriously only a
couple of years old yeah i'm gonna go
look at it real quick
he's gonna go check on the refrigerator
close that [ __ ]
ice is essential in florida it is i
can't drink [ __ ] without ice in it
i have done but i don't like it you know
what i'm saying
yeah we got one of those fridges that
has like the ice maker and the water
thing like in the freezer door
i don't know it's a nice fridge we've
only had it a couple years
but every now and then it just it stops
making ice and i don't know why
i don't know it's a matter of it nothing
works anymore
[Music]
this lighter doesn't work where's my
good one
yeah victor said it's happening right
now with crypto i feel like it's the
same kind of thing
it happens it's it's eternal and people
still keep falling for it
uh thank you david wish i wasn't broke
as [ __ ] yeah i know that feeling
but have money i love y'all wow we love
you too
uh xanada says that a wig jenny yes it
is i like that color
thank you even though in real life
i'm looking at it on the camera and it
is a totally different color than
it is in actuality it's actually purple
but it looks blue i mean
that is clearly purple right yeah uh no
it looks blue does it yeah it's because
the lights
yeah it's just the lights are making it
look blue but it's actually purple
campground i don't understand my hat oh
yeah yeah oh this is my redneck hat it's
kind of collage
when it gets to that level it's i'm
[ __ ] up
when you put that on then you'll just
you'll disappear i don't know what'll
happen
i don't know i've never worn that one
that one's reserved
okay that one's reserved for bad [ __ ]
okay that's when i gotta go full redneck
oh no one wants that no no one wants
that to happen let me get another one
is that the last pack yeah you smoked
all the other ones when we were at at
mannequins the other night yeah
i bought those because i thought oh he'd
get a light
he'd like to have one every now and then
he smoked my whole pack at [ __ ] the
halloween party the other night
halfway to halloween yeah xander says
blue on camera it's totally purple
though
it really is i promise yeah tom should
have a mullet wig
for defcon 6 beast mode yeah
i mean i mean you do have the michael
caine wig
you got that over there yeah you could
bust that out that's right here though
i could wear a wig and a hat at the same
time oh
[ __ ] we've never seen that level never
know what might happen
don't tease me like that don't tease me
like that i'm so used to being let down
by your teasing and then nothing
okay
yeah i don't know why the ice maker
stopped making eyes
i adjusted everything [ __ ] [ __ ] that ice
maker
maybe maybe it's an unpredictable man he
is yeah
that's true okay
victor victor says back in the 90s my
friend got what do you want
i need an ashtray too you know well i
put that over there because i thought
pookie was gonna when she was in here
i thought she was gonna jump up and
knock it off all right
victor says back in the 90s my friend
got hired at mcdonald's just to answer
the phone
answer questions about which beanie
babies they had yeah remember that and
like in the 80s there was a whole thing
with
um cabbage patch kids too
which like i said when i was a kid
listen to this [ __ ]
when i was a kid my parents could not
afford cabbage patch kids
so my mom made
me cabbage patch kids she had like she
bought like the little doll head
and then she sewed the body and she
sewed all the clothes and put hair on it
and everything it was
awesome because she couldn't afford to
buy a cabbage basket
but it was the same kind of thing like
she made little adoption papers and all
this [ __ ] my mom's awesome
so you know the um
yes i just wanted to say that you guys
are going to plug it again
watch elvis and nixon you can stream it
you can probably watch for free on some
of them services
but we're going to be we're going to be
doing a review on it uh
in the next couple days but that'll
probably be up when next week sometime
it'll probably be
sunday we'll probably review it sunday
yeah
i think you guys will find that an
enjoyable movie i mean i liked it like i
said it's not super action-packed or
anything because it's all about that one
particular event it's funny that man i
found it very very funny
yeah it's funny and it's not played up
for laughs
it's actually just showing you how
[ __ ] odd these
these people were and uh i like the fact
that
the dude is playing elvis isn't doing an
elvis impersonation
he says he tried to stay away from that
yeah it's michael shannon michael
shannon played elvis in this who's
he also played uh i'm pretty sure he
played iceman right he played kuklinski
in the iceman he was also in bug
with ashley judd check that [ __ ] out we
need to review that one of these days
you would probably love that [ __ ]
movie but what he does
is he just he says he just tried to put
himself
into elvis's mindset and and trying to
figure out what he's thinking
and not trying to do an impersonation
which yeah
camp guy also points out there was
another good movie called frost to nixon
which uh i actually also saw in the
theater but i think it was before i met
you
and it was about a kind of famous nixon
was interviewed by
uh i think he worked for the bbc
and it was like a real famous interview
that they did and the whole movie was
like about that
and that was also actually really good
if you want to uh
see that as well i would like to see a
movie about james brown now
remember we watched that documentary
about him which was really good
i would like to see a movie about some
[ __ ] adventure
that james brown went on oh my god
they've never made one of them
no not that not something that happened
to james brown
to give us an idea of what he was like
you know victor says uh yeah he says did
you all overwatch take shelter that is
still on my list
i know michael shannon's in that and i
need to see that as well because i keep
seeing it like i think it's on netflix
and i keep scrolling past it i'm like
goddamn it i still need to watch that
and i still haven't watched it yet
but i will i promise it's on my list
it's on my list i promise
i feel like my wig is falling off is it
no it didn't look like it
okay looks normal to me yeah it did kind
of go back on your head a little bit
yeah yeah it did that's what i'm saying
push it
push it forward there you go push it
forward
that's like goodbye that's the first
time you've worn that one
yeah i just got what it is it's heavy in
the back and you're gonna have to put
safety pins or bobby pins there are
bobby pins
up in the front they keep it from there
are bobby pins okay
but yeah that's right obviously it's not
working
thank you victor here have some money
thank you thank you very much garcia
thank you you demand picture says just
watch it
okay i will
yeah did franklin angela play nixon in
that i feel like he did
yeah i saw that in the theater that was
a really good movie
in this movie nixon does some funny [ __ ]
too like uh
he tries to act like a badass and then
he also tries to act cool at one point
he goes so elvis uh you think i could
take him
yeah he's [ __ ] asking somebody before
elvis is
[Laughter]
and the part where he's talking on the
phone to like julie nixon
and she well she was kind of the one
that you know
wanted him to meet elvis she was a big
elvis fan and then he's like talking to
her afterward and he's like yeah i met
elvis blah blah blah it's like maybe
your dad's cooler than you thought then
he's like trying to spin the gun he's
like
yeah he was very nice he was very well
informed
[Laughter]
yeah it's super funny yeah
and then [ __ ] elvis does karate for
nixon does a karate [ __ ] this
demonstration yeah he does a
demonstration yeah
now this all got passed this all this
[ __ ] checked out you know
with uh well people reported buddies
they recorded some of them said yeah he
did that [ __ ]
and like i said jerry shilling was there
and he was the one that
would produce this movie so he's still
alive so he was like talking about it a
bunch of elvis magic happens
when he does this over people it's
almost like sabella lugosi
yeah miss dam and [ __ ] sometimes
gets donuts at a black doughnut shop
he's got maple bars he's got maple bars
in the [ __ ] baby that's really good
black dudes tested him and [ __ ] yeah
but
but then he passed the test so they they
hung out for a while just
the posse tried to the [ __ ] memphis
mob tried to get him out of there come
on man let's go you know we're gonna
get some maple bars they said they're
eating maple bars
while black women black women was
[ __ ] heckling him about being a
ripoff
it's [ __ ] funny man but everyone yeah
the [ __ ] that they said well because
she said to him he was like ordering
something like the original
brother and she's like yeah original my
ass yeah original
and then later on he's like i would like
some more of these original my ass
[Laughter]
it's just like really really funny i
mean the [ __ ] shit's funny like i
said it's low-key funny but it's still
funny
so yeah so we watched that last night
and then we
watched what batman
the dark knight rises watch all three of
them but it took us a while
well we watched the first two i had seen
the first one batman begins
these are the uh you know the way
the dark night and then the dark knight
rises should we freeze out two and three
now we freeze up okay my ship okay her
[ __ ] froze up over here
we'll see it might it might come back we
don't yeah we've been streaming for a
while
yeah it's been it's two hours and 38
minutes which actually that's pretty
good like that we went that long without
it [ __ ]
[ __ ] up it'll catch up there it is
it's trying to catch up see it's trying
i'm not gonna touch anything i'm just
hoping yeah you touch it and [ __ ] locks
[Laughter]
i'm just kind of hoping that it resolves
itself
but yeah we watched that and as we were
watching it even though i think i dozed
off a couple times while we were
watching it
i think i realized that the dark knight
rises the one with bane
yeah was i had never sat
down and watched that entire movie yeah
i mean either i remembered part of it
like i remembered the
[ __ ] with the bomb i remember that i
remembered some of the [ __ ] with
catwoman
i remembered some of the scenes but i
was like i have never actually sat down
and watched this entire movie at the
same time
yeah ever it was okay i don't like it as
much as the other two though
the first one is the best one batman
begins is the best one
yeah that one i've probably seen that
one more than any of the other ones
these are the christopher nolan ones
but i don't know i think like i said i
was pretty tired so i
i think i kind of like stacked all the
pillows up because we have like a
ridiculous like pillow mountain
oh yeah it's too big well i like that
too many stuff
too many stuff too many stuff can we say
where we got that yeah you can go ahead
that's a chinese moment said it too many
i got too many stuff it was a you know
what we got that from
it was hoarders hoarders yeah it was an
episode of hoarders
yeah and there was this tiny tiny little
chinese woman yeah
and she had a a townhouse or an
apartment or something
yeah and she had a bunch of [ __ ] no she
was a lovely woman
and she seemed to know that she had that
she had a problem which a lot of these
hoarders don't that whole house was
filled with stuff
drove the husband out yeah everybody
kind of left
and then but that was kind of one of the
things that made us laugh was that she
said to the show she's like
i just i have too many stuff she said i
have too many stuff
i got too many stuff i got too many
stuff yeah so
we saw that like several years ago and
that just made us laugh so
now every time somebody's like has too
much stuff we always say yeah
you got too many stuff but you know she
knew she had too many stuff
now they're going they want moon pies
[Laughter]
i really hope this doesn't crash and be
really upset my obs
is still going but my youtube uh my
youtube has crashed
yeah okay um so i can't see the chat you
can still see
the chat yeah all right so we're just
going to keep going and keep going
because it's showering it usually
resolves itself in the end if i
leave it alone like i said as long as i
don't touch anything
it should be okay as long as i don't
touch anything until it
freezes up and then well that happened
during our brimstone trickle show
yeah and it did actually record
everything until the end until i said
goodbye even though my [ __ ] was
[ __ ] up at this end all right so what
else do we have to talk about today do
we have to talk about anything else
probably not anybody got any more
questions about uh the great elvis
presley
[Laughter]
or i can explain most of it i've been
[ __ ] collecting
a whole file on [ __ ] mr presley he
has
you have a file i have a whole file it's
all in my head oh okay
i'm gonna put it in my chicken scratch i
write about like elvis writes
you do actually yeah it's a good thing
that [ __ ] everything's on
rarely write anymore now that you have
tablets now funny everything's just
[ __ ] on the keyboard
yeah yeah you try to write something and
you go like wait hold on how did
you just do it wait wait wait there we
go
like a child i have beautiful
handwriting why did you say something i
never had good handwriting my penmanship
always sucked
yeah i can't even read how to show you
luckily i don't have to like luckily you
don't
don't have to write anything down for me
the only the only thing that i have in
here that you wrote down
was the wi-fi password yeah can you read
it
uh sort of sorry
[Laughter]
well i know what it is now so it's just
kind of like my shit's all kind of
depending on what mood i am it's like
spiky
romanesque looking kind of stuff
my cursive isn't bad it's just that i'm
out of practice
yeah yeah well the thing about it is you
know i'm a writer and one of my things
is that when i'm writing a novel not so
much nonfiction but i'm writing a novel
i like to write everything by hand first
like in a notebook
yeah and then when i because then that
way when i
type it it's almost kind of like a
second draft yeah because i could fix it
like when i'm typing it
so i don't know i just like to do that
not with the non-fiction but with the
fiction i do that
somebody said elvis's widow is probably
one of the is they say elvis's widow is
one of the richest gals in hollywood
lisa marie something no his his widow
was [ __ ]
priscilla cilla he called her cilla
i don't think she's alive though is she
isn't still a dead
i don't think so okay so is that that is
she i don't know
holy crap
i don't think so i don't know if she
lives in graceland i don't think she
does
because um i think they gave tours to it
for a while last i heard and this was
like uh
late 90s graceland kind of looked very
very dated
in the late 90s it's all 70s interiors
well they haven't updated it nothing's
updated it's almost it's like a museum
piece
right they want it to be the same as it
was when elvis died i would presume
and uh because why would you modernize
it the problem is
is that a lot of 70s stuff wasn't built
to last
and it starts to fade and it was
to decompose a lot of it is rayons that
they don't make any more
nylons that aren't made anymore they
really weren't built to last and
i bet you there was a lot of damn wood
paneling that old cheap wood paneling
and some of that stuff
i'd have to see it i know there were a
lot of beads and shag
carpet and white leather
[ __ ] uh sofas and [ __ ]
yeah i remember that yeah i remember
though yeah
it's probably pretty damn tacky by
today's standards i'd like to see it
i don't know some of that stuff is kind
of tacky some of the stuff is kind of
cool but
not so much i i don't like the wood
paneling i don't like the white leather
[ __ ] i like some of those lamps though
you know how you remember watching
boogie nights yeah and uh
in burt reynolds's house he had like i
don't give a [ __ ] about like the faux
stone on the walls and [ __ ] that's tacky
but he had like this really cool hanging
lamp like over the bar
and my grandma had one that was kind of
like that it was like cylindrical
and it has like all these crystals like
hanging on it
so you shine the light through it it
makes like all these cool like light
patterns and whatnot
my grandma's was bigger than that it was
green
and it was like i loved that [ __ ]
lamp i i think somebody else took it
like after she died unfortunately but
i really really wanted it i think my
[ __ ] crashed but is it still going okay
yeah it's good
victor garcia said the sill is still
alive yeah i thought she was she's not
that old
yeah danny goes says that elvis price
still lives in the upstairs at graceland
i went around to see no need for me
to said uh they probably didn't hold up
well now i
i heard in the late 90s it wasn't
holding up too well those interiors
like i said 70s stuff a lot of it was
not built to last it was kind of
it was almost kind of like it was just
this looks super looks
type of stuff a lot of it's plastic a
lot of the [ __ ] from the 70s like people
talked about [ __ ] later on but like [ __ ]
from the 70s it's just
it was all just like the cheapest
material they could get their [ __ ]
hands on everything was like press board
and [ __ ]
[ __ ] you get from ikea nowadays is
probably better quality than that ship
yeah
because i remember you know we still
going
yeah we're still going my shit's
crashing at this end yeah i don't know
what the [ __ ] going on if the guys
crashes do you want to uh
do you want to continue the stream or do
you want to end the stream if it crashes
we'll give them a heads up well what are
you looking at me for i can't like my
chat's gone
no i gotta hear i'm asking you if it
crashes do you want to end the show or
do you want to
restart well i mean we've been going
almost three hours so i think it crashes
we'll just
end the show i guess so yeah so if it
crashes people we won't be coming plus i
feel like my wig's sliding off
yeah just kind of a little bit a little
bit of black showing there well you
can't really see it on camera
priscilla's 75
gonna be 76 this month okay not as old
as i thought she was
it's like i said that elvis died young
he was like 42 43
something yeah it was like yeah like i
said he was a lot younger than me
and he was a lot younger than he looked
he looked a little older it was because
of that weight
and uh drugs
and opiates yeah drugs
well that's kind of a bad connotation
you know i mean there they are drugs but
they weren't recreational drugs he was
addicted to the things that they had
prescribed him
he became men physically and mentally
dependent on him
but honestly i don't really think that's
that's i don't think he realized he was
a drug addict
well yeah and to me i think that's part
of the problem because
i think people don't see an addiction to
prescription drugs
as as bad as an addiction to illegal
drugs even though sometimes the
prescription
ones could be worse yeah potentially
depending on what it is
so i feel like it's funny that people
make that distinction because i don't
really think there's much of a
distinction
here's the funny thing though about this
that movie elvis
elvis and nixon he goes to nixon to
become basically a drug czar
an anti-drug czar and to fight the drug
war
and he's loaded off his ass which that
was the funny thing
to me this is during the time when he
was addicted to all that stuff well yeah
and i like well and i like the fact that
the movie didn't
lean too much into that yeah they just
kind of trusted you
to know that he didn't know that that
was what was happening and that was
where the comedy was mined from
so you know so the movie kind of like
let you
yeah make your own joke at that point i
don't think elvis realized it though
i don't think he did either he wasn't
conscious well like i said i think they
made a distinction between stuff that a
doctor gave you like it was medicine
like you said
or like illegal drugs because he was
very against
all these hippies and they're all
smoking pot and doing lsd and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
he saw that is fundamentally different
to what he was doing
yeah well even though i would argue that
it's pretty much the same thing
yeah but he wasn't really talking about
i know he's talking i know what he meant
he wasn't he didn't really say it was
the drugs that was the problem
he thought that the drugs were being put
in there
by communist agents yeah
so it wasn't so much the drugs he
thought that the drugs are being used
by um basically the kgb
to um help break america apart
that's what he had look it came back
yeah it does that every now and then
yeah he thought it was part of a
government of a soviet
government effort to ship drugs into the
country and to [ __ ] break it apart
which i don't know if he knew about mk
ultra at that time
the kgb may have been interested in
something like that but i don't think
they would have to
i think there are people a lot of people
ready to import drugs illegally into the
united states through mexico
all that money you wouldn't need the
soviets to do that
well yeah no why would you no you'd have
players here that would do that
yeah uh but i think elvis thought it was
the department
and our government was experimenting
with that [ __ ] too like different
branches of it so
yeah and then you know a lot of the
ruling class
families that have the money to run for
office were involved in all that kind of
stuff
so and then they get elected and you
have elected officials
and [ __ ] around with the damn drug
trade to help
fuel their campaigns what's up oh my
goodness what anyone go outside
what's up she came up behind
both of our chairs and went yeah but you
know
elvis was seeing it in kind of simple
simplistic terms
if it was bad for the united states and
that came from an outside force and the
soviets must be doing it that's what he
was talking about
yeah um but i don't think the soviets
were doing it i don't think they had the
power to do it
well that's the thing it's like whatever
time period it is whatever bad is
happening you always attribute it to
whoever the boogeyman of the day the day
was right you know what i mean it was
just
it was the same up until the 80s it was
like oh the [ __ ]
the russians are doing that kind of [ __ ]
yeah
even though they probably weren't doing
like [ __ ] eighty percent of the [ __ ]
we attributed
it to them it was just kind of like they
were the boogeyman at the time so they
were doing a lot of stuff but they
didn't i don't think they had the power
to do that
that's what i mean i i don't think they
had the power that people attributed it
to them well i think that's kind of true
of every boogeyman of every yeah
they don't have the power to do all the
[ __ ] that you think that they can do now
if you go back
if you go back in history and see who
who this who's who the leaders of the
soviet union were what kind of guy it
was
they were stiff shirt [ __ ]
themselves they didn't they weren't the
kind of people that could go down and
interact with [ __ ] mexican drug
cartels if they existed at that time
they probably didn't
and [ __ ] cut some deals to ship [ __ ]
in and somehow
disintegrate the united states and
russia is going to spend money on this
they didn't russia didn't have the money
russia's solution to the united states
is always just make more tanks
that's what the russians did let's make
some more tanks
you know what no let's make some more
tanks that seems like a good solution
yeah this
always worked before yeah let's just
make some more tanks and that was the
russian solution to everything
they had a [ __ ] seat you might need
them might need some more tanks
americans are going to come [ __ ] with us
make some more tanks and it was all
took the same tank over and over again
and uh yeah well that was part of the
problem with the soviet union even guys
that you know
that went through the collapse and were
able to speak afterwards and just they
kind of made
fun of the soviet defense industry when
in doubt
just make some more tanks i mean they
they had so many and they know what to
do with them they had
they didn't even couldn't even really
like uh
didn't really have the money to fuel all
these tanks and to train all these tank
crews they mostly just sat around
like monuments make some more tanks
they're like we're gonna end up turning
these into apartments
at some point well they were kind they
weren't very
creative contrary to what a lot of
people think the soviets weren't very
creative
well like i said people like to imagine
yeah
that whoever the boogeyman of the day is
you know is a lot more
is a lot smarter than you is a lot more
savvy than you they're just a dumb
[ __ ] like you
are it's fine and the soviet union they
were
they couldn't make the nintendo all
right
they wanted the nintendo play system
they got a ripoff version of a bootleg
copy of it from uh
thailand i think it was thailand
oh i remember that story yeah so
then they bootlegged all the [ __ ]
games
yeah copyrighted games yeah but they had
to put a soviet touch on them
yeah which is to [ __ ] them up they would
[ __ ] them up every time you got killed
skulls would appear just whatever
they [ __ ] up they [ __ ] up louis was
it
super mario brothers they [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] up
some of the stuff they made it so it was
kind of unplayable
no it but if you have one of those old
soviet
consoles it's evidently worth a lot of
money to collectors
well i imagine because they were
immediately thrown away i mean
when new stuff came out [ __ ] that
just
well once new [ __ ] came out they threw
them away yeah but um
no i mean i've heard that a soviet like
a commie
[ __ ] a commie knockoff of nintendo is
[ __ ] worth a lot of money new super
nintendo
yeah did we crash no
yeah yeah we did yeah we didn't crash
yeah we did we crashed
oh well can we still talk yeah
is it still going i don't know yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe i went back
didn't hear us
okay [ __ ] yeah you guys can't hear us
right
you're way ahead of the [ __ ] because my
just crashed this [ __ ] here
is getting ready i know it's making me
really
yeah i mean it's gone on a long time but
yeah they're going they said they can't
hear us and then we're going
it's been going a long time but let's
get my way back
it's it's it's it's um showing sign oh
look
oh no no no no oh did we
creep show christmas special every year
yes or no
should they do it every year oh yes yes
i mean they should do a halloween
special and a christmas special
okay just saying well look people
i think this [ __ ] is going to crash
probably we should end this stream
now well we're still about out with
[ __ ] honor
honor so it's not just like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
at the end
like some of our other ones we've been
going for like three hours that's almost
about the limit for this [ __ ]
although like it's i'm proud of this
[ __ ] it's been better
it usually crashes about 50 minutes for
whatever reason
yeah but it kind of wanted to but then
it kept on going
so i'm proud of it good job laptop
yeah um but yeah so what's today it's
wednesday you're saying you can
have a homework today's wednesday yeah
tomorrow i gotta go to the
va yeah you gotta go to the va you gotta
go to doctor tomorrow yeah it's for his
annual checkup yeah or a six month
checkup
but yeah so we will be back friday
evening
uh friday evening uh the patreon poll
was
tied so we're doing two topics on the
show that have nothing to do with one
another but it should be fun
we're doing the anthill kids cult and
we're
also doing the disappearance of amelia
earhart on the same show
on the same show you'll never fit it in
there yes i will okay
[ __ ] if you don't like talk the whole
time i can fit all kind of crap in there
all right you know what i mean okay just
like
you're saying i'm filling up the show
yeah well no i'm just saying
you'd be surprised how much [ __ ] i can
fit into a small
small space i'll just sit here and drink
and observe then
he's going to drink and observe tom ross
drink and observe
that's what he does yeah but that's what
friday's show is going to be about
and that'll be the next time that we
will be on live yes great chat guys
thank you for showing
up all our [ __ ] regulars and we will
be with you guys uh
friday night friday night friday night
we're doing 6 p.m right we're not going
out after so
yeah we do six yeah it should be 6 p.m
all right
so thank you everybody for dropping by
as always
thank you for hanging out with us thank
you for all your donations and fun
conversation
we will see you guys friday night thanks
for hanging out with us
see you later bye